ich dann rausgefunden habe,
wer das organisiert hatte bei Ihnen,
habe ich dem mal ein paar Sticker für den mitgegeben.
Nice.
Er kriegt als Montag ein paar Sticker.
Sticker sind doch auch immer super.
Ja.
Send Sticker to your friends and Glitter to your enemies.
Gibt es die Seite eigentlich noch,
diese sendyourenemiesglitter.com?
Weiß ich nicht.
Beziehungsweise gab es noch eine Alternative,
die Glitzer nicht nur verschickt haben,
sondern in so einer
langen Tube mit einer Spring
drin hatten.
ShipYourEnemiesGlitter.com
Da kann man auch
ShipYourEnemiesPoo.com oder so,
wo du halt wirklich so kacke, also literally
Fäkalien verschicken konntest.
Fand ich auch ein spannendes Konzept.
Da gibt es unterschiedliche Sachen.
The Glitter Bomb,
9.99,
A Bag of Dicks,
das sind aber Gummibärchen in Penisform,
Ah, auch nicht schlecht.
A Bag of Dirt,
quasi ein Dirtbag.
Textbomb
Aha
Was es nicht alles gibt, stell dir vor, du kannst
irgendwann mal hier
bist eingeladen, über erfolgreiche
Startup-Gründung zu reden und dann erzählst du, dass du
das machst. Ich bin übrigens
der Gründer von shipyouranimatesglitter.com
Besser als wenn du
von dem Fäkalien-Startup bist.
Am besten verkaufen sich die
Bag of Dicks Gummibärchen, die schmecken nämlich
einfach super lecker.
Verkaufen die Leute sich auch selbst.
Warum nicht?
Ja. Wollen wir langsam anfangen.
Machen wir das. Geil.
Hi Kilian. Hi Hendrik.
Du, ich glaube, wir müssen uns bei unseren Zuhörern
entschuldigen. Ach, wieso das denn?
Ja, wir haben relativ viele Kommentare
auf die letzte Sendung bekommen. Die Leute haben einfach
nichts verstanden.
Sophia.
Aber krass, es gab wirklich so viele Kommentare wie bisher noch nie auf diversen Kanälen.
Es tut uns echt leid, dass die Audioqualität ein bisschen gelitten hat bei der letzten Folge.
Vielleicht sollten wir mit solchen Sachen häufiger mal ein bisschen rumspielen,
einfach mal ein bisschen rauszufinden, wer unsere Zuhörer tatsächlich sind.
Ah, das ist sogar jetzt gerade schon unangenehm auf den Kopf.
Nee, also tut uns leid, wir haben echt gekämpft.
Das habe ich auch auf den Social-Media-Kanälen hinterher nochmal steif und fest behauptet.
Und zwar haben wir das von Anfang an auch so gehört.
Ich hatte den Eindruck, es hörte sich mit der Zeit weg.
Live hatten wir die Probleme nicht so hart, oder?
Das war schon irgendwie.
Wir hatten bloß noch das zuhörige Problem der immensen Latenz,
die du ja Gott sei Dank noch rausediten konntest.
Ja, ich habe sehr viel Luft hinterher noch rausgelöscht.
Und ich dachte mir, ah, naja, vielleicht ist das einfach,
Jörg, mach mal lieber noch eine lokale Aufnahme dazu.
Und dann hat er uns das geschickt.
Und dann habe ich mir das beides angehört.
Und das war kein Deut besser.
Und dann habe ich einfach genau die Aufnahme genommen,
die wir auch per Studiolink bekommen haben.
Das war besser als gar nichts, aber
das nächste Mal werden wir mehr drauf achten.
Was auch noch gut war, war das Feedback vom
Schmittlauch, dass die
Schmittlauch oder Herr Schmittlauch?
Zumindest das Feedback von ihm war
mit
WLAN gibt es noch mehr Latenz, weil ich mich
auch gewundert habe, wie viel
das war da, zwei Sekunden. Ja, es war wirklich so
ZDF-Auslandskorrespondent. Ja, vor allem
es ist halt Peer-to-Peer.
Wir hatten gleichzeitig noch
das Web-Adresse-basierte
Kommunikationsprodukt, an dem ich arbeite,
laufen als Backup.
Stimmt, wir hatten diverse Sachen.
Und das hatte nicht so eine Latenz.
Und in meiner Erfahrung sind solche
Peer-to-Peer-Anwendungen mit wesentlich mehr Latenz
versehen. Auch Palawa TV, was
ja Leute hier aus Dresden gebaut hatten, hatte
gefühlt, weil es direkt das Peer-to-Peer-Web-Adresse
war, eine wesentlich höhere Latenz
als irgendwas, was du über irgendeinen
Amazon-Service routest. Und ich schätze einfach,
dass es schon einen Unterschied dazwischen gibt,
wie du im Internet geroutet wirst.
Ja, auf jeden Fall gibt es einen Unterschied.
Aber dass der auch so immens spürbar ist, war schon
beeindruckend. Also das hat mich gewundert.
Ich habe da so eine Schere im Kopf gehabt
und habe mir gedacht, ja klar, der Jörg sitzt ja auch in Schottland.
Aber dass ich selber jeden Tag
Videokonferenzen mit Leuten
in Kalifornien habe und wir da nicht
so eine krasse Latenz haben, habe ich in dem Moment überhaupt nicht bedacht.
Zumindest, also es tut uns sehr
leid. Ich hoffe, ihr habt trotzdem
ein bisschen was über
nix
gehört, auch wenn ihr nix
verstanden habt.
es erlaubt einfach
immer, also
die Quelle an
Wortwitzen, die versiegt einfach nicht
herrlich, also
das tut uns sehr leid, aber
wie gesagt, dadurch haben wir auch gehört, wie viele Zuhörer
wir tatsächlich haben, so vielen Dank, dass ihr uns
Feedback gegeben habt und wir freuen uns auch jedes Mal
sehr, ich kann das
nur betonen, wirklich über euer Feedback
wenn ihr uns welches gebt, also bitte auch
jetzt hört nicht auf, selbst
versteht. Schreibt uns
auf Twitter, schreibt uns in unserem
Matrix-Channel. Das kommt
immer gut. Danke auf jeden Fall auch den
allen, die das bisher gemacht haben. Finde ich großartig,
dass wir da
diverse Leute drin haben, die wir über
Themen reden können. Das gefällt mir. Genau, da haben wir bereits
so eine kleine, lebhafte,
akronomisierbare Community, die auch
kein Blatt vor den Mund nimmt und uns erzählt, wenn sie mir
scheiße labern. Ja, auch so
unser Podcast-Motto ist gefährliches Halbwissen.
Gefährliches Halbwissen. Ich habe allerdings
jetzt, ich muss mal einem Pick vorgreifen,
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon kennst, aber
es gibt ein,
ich mache jetzt Ergboot, Podcast.
Das ist aber eigentlich, es ist
halb Podcast oder es ist halb
YouTube-Channel. Es gibt zwei
Entwickler bei Google.
Einer von dem, ich kenne den Namen von dem anderen gar nicht,
aber der eine ist Das Soma.
Dem kann man auf Twitter folgen.
Der ist Web-Entwickler und macht so
auch Web-Assembly-Zeugs
und eigene Keyboards und alles
Mögliche, was halt gerade so hip ist.
Also irgendwie habe ich gerade den Eindruck, jeder baut sich
eigenen Keyboards, das scheint so ein Trend zu sein.
Oder er redet über mechanische Keyboards.
Anyway, der hat einen Podcast
zusammen mit einem anderen
Teammitglied von ihm wahrscheinlich aus
seinem Google-Team.
Und die haben den geilsten Podcast-Namen ever.
Die heißen HTTP 203.
Ach, das ist schon in den Show-Notes.
Okay.
Und
HTTP 203 ist
Unauthoritative Information.
Oh, das ist schon
echt. Das ist einfach mal der
Geilste Podcast-Titel ever.
Warum sind wir da eigentlich nicht drauf gekommen?
Das ist zu clever.
Das übersteigt unser Niveau, mein Vielfaches.
Gut.
Aber man muss zugeben, als wir mit dem Podcast hier angefangen haben,
was mittlerweile auch ein ganzes Weichen her ist, muss ich sagen.
Drei Jahre?
So in etwa.
Waren wir beide noch nicht so wirklich Web-Entwickler.
Also ich bin mittlerweile einigermaßen Web-Entwickler.
Ich war damals mehr Web-Entwickler als heute.
Und du?
Also nicht, aber...
Also damals war ich es auch schon nicht.
Aber ich habe noch mehr Web-Dinge gemacht als heute.
Und mir ist auch...
Ich bin diese Woche nochmal durch einen Kommentar auf einem GitHub-Issue, was du auf Hyper aufgemacht hast, nochmal darauf aufmerksam geworden.
Da hatte jemand nochmal was drunter geschrieben, da war es plötzlich wieder in meinen Notifications.
Und dann ist mir erst mal aufgefallen, fuck, das ist drei Jahre her, dass du mir damit rumgespielt hast.
Old Man yells at Cloud.
Übrigens, die Zeit vergeht ziemlich schnell, also lass uns doch mal über unsere Themen reden.
Was ist denn diese Woche, haha, Woche, was ist denn seit der letzten Podcast-Folge alles so Spannendes passiert bei dir, Kian?
Bei mir? Was habe ich denn so gemacht? Ich habe sehr viel Spaß in der virtuellen Realität gehabt in den letzten Tagen, beziehungsweise in den letzten zwei, drei Wochen.
Ach, das meinst du, dass du mit virtuelle, okay.
Genau, genau.
Nichts von wegen Hypervisor oder...
Nee, nicht auf die Art virtualisiert.
Außerdem ist es ja kriminell, wenn du Virtualbox installiert hast.
Da müssen britische Eltern ihre Kinder der Polizei melden,
dass die über Gefahren von Hacking reden können.
Was?
Das muss ich nicht damals mitbekommen.
Damals, das war auch schon wieder ein Monat her oder so,
da ging so ein Ding rum, das war so eine Infotafel
oder so ein Flyer oder irgendwas von irgendeinem britischen Ministerium.
War nicht explizit die Polizeipolizei.
Ich wette, das war irgendwie so ein Äquivalent von BSI oder BND
oder irgendwie was in die Richtung.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was genau das für eine...
Institution war, aber die hatten
gewarnt,
dass wenn Eltern bestimmte Software
auf den Rechnern ihrer Kinder sehen, dass sie doch mal
bitte ihre Kinder melden
sollen bei Behörde und die Behörde setzt
sich mit denen in Kontakt und spricht mit denen über die
Gefahren von Hacking. Und das war unter anderem
VirtualBox, das war Kali-Linux.
Ich finde es immer geil, wenn Leute Kali
anbringen. Das ist so ein Ding, was ausschließlich
Script-Kinnis nutzen. Was war es noch?
Es war Discord.
Ja, natürlich
ist es gefährlich. Wenn du Discord installiert hast,
Bist du Gamer?
Ja, nee, du bist ein böser Hacker, weil da werden die bösen Hacking-Tools ja ausgetauscht.
Das ist absolut absurd gewesen.
Das war ganz für sich und noch drei andere Sachen, die mir gerade entfallen sind.
Aber fand ich sehr ganz für sich.
Ich dachte, das ist, weil wenn du Gamer bist, bist du ja potenzieller Attentäter.
Nee, super, das hat sich gar nicht gemeint.
Nee, aber apropos Gaming.
Ich habe mit einer VR-Brille Spaß gehabt, habe ich mir mal angelacht.
Und auch wenn es mir sehr im Herzen wehtut,
dass das Ding ein Facebook-Produkt ist mittlerweile.
Ah, du hast ja die, wie heißt sie?
Die Oculus Quest.
Ich will auch gar keine Werbung für die machen.
Ich meine, wir haben ja eh alle einen Facebook-Account.
Die Glücklichen von uns haben mehrere.
Die Unglücklichen haben einen.
Brauchst du dazu einen Facebook-Account?
Nee, brauchst du nicht.
Du kannst ja auch einen, ich meine,
wir haben alle einen Account,
weil wir alle Shadow-Profile bei Facebook haben.
Ach so.
Und die Glücklichen haben halt mehrere,
weil Facebook die nicht zusammengelegt bekommt.
Aber letztendlich haben wir alle mindestens eins.
Ob das jetzt öffentlich ist oder nicht.
Ich habe kein öffentliches, also nur ein inoffizielles Shadow-Profil.
Benutzt du noch manchmal Facebook?
Ich habe keinen Account bei Facebook. Hast du jemals
einen gehabt? Ich habe mal einen gehabt, ja.
Ich glaube nämlich auch, dass ich dich nicht mehr
wieder benutzen werde, um mit alten
Klubfreunden Kontakt aufzunehmen.
Ich lösche den Scheiß.
Dann kriegen die zumindest mit, auch durch fallende Zahlen,
dass sie an der irrelevant landen,
beziehungsweise die Menschen da
eine Meinung zu haben.
Aber, was soll ich sagen?
Genau, du brauchst keinen Facebook-Account dafür.
Mir tut es bloß ein bisschen leid, dass es die Firma mitfinanziert.
Aber ich wollte die Hardware mal ausprobieren,
weil mir sehr gefällt, dass das Ding ein Standalone-Ding ist
und keinen Rechner braucht, an dem das mit dranhängt,
sondern du hast nur die Brille und die zwei Controller,
du setzt das Ding auf und bist halt direkt in der VR-Welt drin.
Und was mich, ich bin ein bisschen late to the game,
das weiß ich mit so einer Hardware,
das läuft schon seit Jahren,
aber ich war literally blown away,
wie fucking gut das Tracking-Darkfunktion funktioniert.
Ich habe tatsächlich seit der letzten Folge
auch mal so ein Ding auf der Nase gehabt,
weil ich einen Freund besucht habe, der das auch hat.
Und das Witzige bei ihm ist, dass er eigentlich sehr, sehr schlechte Augen hat.
Er ist auf einem Auge blind und auf dem anderen sieht er extrem stehen.
Trotzdem hat er super Spaß an sowas.
Und er hat sich halt so ein bisschen Platz in seinem Wohnzimmer gemacht.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es bei dir aussieht, ob du dir so eine...
Es gibt keine dedizierte Nische.
Es gibt einfach den Platz im Wohnzimmer, wo ich mir den Tisch ein bisschen beiseite schiebe, den Couchtisch.
Das könnte bei mir hier eigentlich auch ganz gut sein.
Bei dir passt das wunderbar.
Du hast massiv Platz dafür.
Außerdem hast du den geilen Vorteil, dass du den Teppich auf dem Boden hast, in der Mitte vom Zimmer.
Und der auf allen Seiten endet.
Sprich, du könntest mit den Füßen auch ertasten.
Ah, das ist natürlich ein guter Punkt.
Aber ansonsten macht das die Brille ja sehr gut.
In dem Sinne, dass du zum einen erstmal die Gegend erkannt wird, in der du bist.
Und dann halt direkt erstmal so ein Guardian-Area-Dings auf dem Boden malst.
Und allein das funktioniert schon so gut.
Da war ich schon begeistert von der Hardware.
Also das Geilste fand ich eigentlich, dass es diesen Übergang gemacht hat.
Also wir machen ja mal überhaupt keine Werbung dafür.
Aber dass du durch den Raum gehst und dann plötzlich diese Holodeck-Kacheln vor dir auftauchen.
Also du hast wirklich diese Matrix-Linien von dem Bereich, in dem du dich bewegen kannst.
Achso, ja, ja, genau.
Und du gehst ein bisschen rum und plötzlich hast du diese virtuelle Grenze, wo du weißt, ah ja, hier ist safe.
Weil es gibt nichts Schlimmeres, als so ein Ding auf den Augen zu haben, vielleicht noch was auf den Ohren zu haben und absolut ausgeliefert zu sein,
weil dir plötzlich irgendeiner dich anrempelt oder du gegen irgendwas gegenläufst oder mit dem Fuß gegen irgendwas gegentrittst.
Was übrigens sehr viel Spaß macht, ist, wenn du die Controller in der Hand hast,
die haben so einen Strick dran, also so ein Bändel,
mit dem du dir die Arme sichern kannst, dass du sie nicht durch die Kante wirfst.
Wenn du das nicht an deinen Armen machst,
weil du denkst, du wirfst deine Arme jetzt gerade nicht durch die Kante
und du bist in der VR-Welt und plötzlich zieht es deinen Arm runter,
weil eine Katze dieses Bändel gesehen hat.
Ich wollte gerade fragen, wie vereinbart man sowas mit Katzen?
Weil die laufen ja trotzdem.
Das geht ganz gut in dem Sinne, dass du nicht viel durch die Gegend rennst in der VR-Welt.
Du bewegst dich physisch wenig, eigentlich bewegt sich hauptsächlich dein Oberkörper.
Manchmal gehst du so einen Schritt zur Seite und dann
trampelst du nicht rum, sondern bewegst sie, also
du schaffst es kurz mit deinen Füßen zur Seite und wenn
eine Katze sein sollte zufällig, dann
trittst du sie nicht weg, sondern du spürst, dass
die da ist. Also das ist eigentlich kein
Problem. Das ist witzig, wenn die Katze
halt das Bände sieht und mit dir spielen möchte
und dein Arm plötzlich, ohne dass du
was mitbekommen hast, so nach unten zerrt.
What the fuck war das jetzt?
Aber dem Beat Saber
Spiel macht tierisch Spaß, habe ich gelernt.
Ah ja, genau. Das ist ein witziges Spiel.
Unsere Kollegen in dem Büro
in Karlsruhe haben sich so eine große
grüne Hölle
gebaut.
So eine Greenscreen-Raum-Geschichte.
Und da haben sie richtig
dieses Setup gehabt, dass du dann von hinten auch noch
gefilmt wirst und virtuell da reinprojiziert wirst.
Dann habe ich Videos, wie ich
dieses Lightsaber-Spiel spiele.
Man sieht die auf YouTube. Ich frage mich immer, wie die Leute das machen.
Die musst du ja irgendwie ein Greenscreen-Raum-Setup haben
mit Kamera hinten.
Und da gibt es auch ein schönes Video von meinem Chef,
wie er sich das Ding aufsetzt
und die Musik hört und dann irgendwie
anfängt rumzufriebeln und dann kommt von hinten einer
an, weil er noch nicht auf diesen Punkten
steht, wo es am besten getrackt
werden kann und die dann so vorsichtig
ein Stückchen nach vorne
schiebt und er dann anfängt zu spielen.
Das ist total putzig. Das muss ich mal aus unserem Slack
raussuchen. Sehr witzig.
Ich bin, wie gesagt, stark
begeistert von was
die Hardware da hergibt. Mal abgesehen davon, was das
für Hardware genau ist, was wir da aktuell schon
an Tracking hinkriegen und wie
stabil das Head-Tracking und das
Arm-Tracking läuft, ist
beeindruckend. Das habe ich nicht erwartet.
Ich dachte, das wäre noch viel freckliger, als es es wäre.
Ich meine,
wenn du darüber nachdenkst,
solche Motion Tracker gibt es ja
seit der Nintendo Wii eigentlich.
Ja, aber das war noch auf einem ganz anderen Level.
Das ist zehn Jahre noch.
Mehr als zehn Jahre her, oder? Die Wii gibt es
seit fast 20 Jahren.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, Quatsch.
So lange gibt es die Wii nicht.
Gibt es Zeitleidig mit der ersten Xbox sogar?
Nee, Quatsch.
So, warte, jetzt haben wir natürlich hier
Unauthoritative Information erreicht.
Die Xbox gibt es 100 pro schon ein gutes Stück länger.
Ich weiß noch,
wie immer diese komischen Familien,
mein Onkel hatte sich damals eine Xbox zugelegt
und wir hatten irgendwann ganz spät mal eine Wii gekauft.
Das war mindestens gefühlt 10 Jahre später.
Nintendo Wii gibt es seit 2006.
Joa.
Das ist...
Das ist länger als ich gedacht habe.
Aber das ist 100 pro...
Also Tracking von solchen Sachen
im Raum ist mittlerweile offenbar
gelöstes Problem.
Einigermaßen. Ja, aber auch, dass du deine
die, okay, die Xbox
gibt es seit 2001. Fünf Jahre unterschied.
Genau. Na gut.
Ich hätte einen größeren Unterschied erwartet. Also was,
worauf ich als nächstes warte bei diesen Spielen, ist eigentlich, dass
du Multiplayer machen kannst.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das nicht vielleicht sogar schon gibt, aber
dass du zwei
solche Brillen aufsetzt und die sich gegenseitig
tracken und dir dann einen Avatar
in den Raum projizieren. Das ist wahrscheinlich... Da gibt's
schon Anwendungen für. VR-Chat zum Beispiel.
Was ich sehr witzig finde, es gibt so Dinge, da
kannst du dich gemeinsam mit deinen Freunden in den Kinosaal
setzen und eigene Videos schauen.
Stimmt.
Das wirkt erstmal mega dumm von der Idee her.
Ich war sehr skeptisch, aber ich habe es einmal ausprobiert
und es war gar nicht so dämlich,
wie ich dachte.
Tatsächlich hat es was.
Auf jeden Fall.
Gut. Also, beenden wir
mal den Werbeblock. Ich überlege jetzt auch, ob ich
mir vielleicht so ein Ding holen sollte, aber es ist schon ganz schön drüber.
Lassen wir es also mal sein.
Ist auf jeden Fall eine spaßige Spielerei.
Geiler Scheiß.
geiler Scheiß. Ich habe auch so ein bisschen mit Sachen
bei mir zu Hause rumgespielt, nachdem da Jörg
in letzter... Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das verstanden habt, aber wir hatten
irgendwie zwischendurch kurz drüber geredet.
Ich habe mir noch ein bisschen verstanden.
Da hat er halt erzählt, dass er sich so einen
Home Assistant hingestellt hatte.
Und ich dachte mir, Home Assistant, das muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Ich mache mal hier kurz.
Home Assistant ist diese
Plattform für Heimautomisierung, wo du
Plugins und alle mögliche reinwerfen kannst.
Genau, also was ich irgendwann mal gemacht hatte, ist, dass ich mir
hier Lampen von Ikea gekauft habe und dann
hinterher festgestellt habe, da waren Zigbee und Zigbee
das gleiche und dann wollte ich mir
auf einem Raspberry Pi dieses Mozilla
IoT-Gateway einrichten und habe festgestellt,
ja, das kann mit dem Ikea-Zeugs
gar nicht, super, jetzt habe ich mich bekauft und habe irgendwas,
was nicht zusammen geht, dann habe ich mir von Dresden
Elektronik,
das gibt es tatsächlich,
das ist eine Firma, die macht so
Fernsteuertechnik oder sowas, gibt so einen USB-Sigbee-Adapter,
der steuert sich
richtig toll, der hat nämlich ein REST-Interface,
da musst du einen Treiber haben und dann hast du eine
Web-Oberfläche dazu, das kannst du auch noch irgendwie anschließen,
aber zumindest habe ich irgendwann gedacht,
weißt du, das mit dem IoT ist auch eigentlich
Quatsch. Das ist so viel
Frickalei, das muss ich mir nicht antun.
Und dann
hat Jörg davon erzählt, dann dachte ich mir, ja stimmt ja,
Home Assistant gibt es auch noch, das ist einfach so
ein Tool, gibt es auch als
Raspberry Pi Image, läuft dann auch
ein Webservice, dann habe ich mir einen alten Raspberry Pi
rausgekramt, das hat man draufgeschmissen.
Abgesehen, ah, unter den Extensions gibt es auch für das
Ikea Lister Gateway
eine Schnittstelle, die hat also doch
eine API, ich hatte sie bloß damals nicht gefunden.
Und dann habe ich da meine ganzen Geräte drauf geschmissen und es unterstützt meine, ich habe noch zwei alte Fritzbox Powerline Adapter, die du auch einfach als Schalter nehmen kannst.
Die sind also jetzt mit in meinem WLAN drin, damit kann ich zwei Lampen steuern.
dann kannst du meine ganzen Ikea-Lampen besser steuern als die Ikea-App dazu,
weil du tatsächlich sagen kannst, speicher mal dieses Profil insgesamt,
nicht nur pro Gerät, sondern pro Gruppe von Geräten und kannst sie zusammenfassen.
Das ist ziemlich nice.
Ja, und jetzt habe ich da so ein paar Profile reingeschmissen
und ich habe mit Mühe und Not programmiert bekommen,
das morgens um
halb sieben oder
halb acht mein Licht in der
Early-Morning-Szene angeht
und um neun, wenn ich das Haus verlassen habe,
wieder ausgeht.
Das Programmierst allerdings irgendwie durch klicken
und konfigurieren, das ist nicht
super schön und wenn es,
es gibt auch eine Textform, aber das ist YAML.
Das ist alles in einer YAML-Config
irgendwie. Das ist
unterschiedliche YAML-Configuren.
Es geht, es geht auch besser.
Ich habe dann irgendwann aufgehört damit,
das noch krasser zu betreiben.
Aber da geht noch einiges. Also ich habe auch schon mal
ein bisschen auf Twitter rumgefragt, ob es vielleicht mal jemand
für ein Interview zur Verfügung stehen würde.
Ein Kollege von mir zum Beispiel
sagt, ja, ich habe hier,
ich mache so Sachen wie, ich bestelle mir
Feuchtigkeitssensoren bei Alibaba oder
irgendwelche Bewegungssensoren und darauf reagiert
meine Wohnung.
Und die Sachen sprechen
teilweise, also wenn du solche
Blenden an Fenstern hast,
die automatisch runtergehen, die sprechen dann halt
über MQTT miteinander.
Warum nicht?
Okay, also da geht noch einiges mehr.
Ich habe da irgendwann aufgegehört, dass mir reicht,
wenn ich meine Lichter steuern kann. Der Rest ist krank.
Aber es ist schon ziemlich nice.
Also ich habe jetzt,
ich benutze jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr die
Ikea-App auf meinem Telefon und kann
wunderschön irgendwie zwischen unterschiedlichen Lichtmodi
mit Lampen, die überhaupt gar nicht
von dem gleichen Hersteller kommen,
meine Wohnung beleuchten.
Ich habe auch so drei
Ikea-Lampen daheim im Wohnzimmer an der Decke
hängen, nutze aber eigentlich ausschließlich diese
Ikea-Fernbedienung dazu.
die, also witzig,
weil ich habe eigentlich die Lampen installiert,
weil es manchmal nervig war,
auf einer Couch sitzend aufzustehen und das Licht
an und auszuschalten. Und ich dachte,
ja, es ist so schlimm, so ein First-World-Problem,
aber ich dachte mir, jetzt steht der HomePod eh schon da,
dann kann ich das doch auch über Siri machen und sagen,
Siri, Licht an, aus, und dann geht das auch.
Das geht wunderbar. Das Witzige
ist, also ich nutze eigentlich nur diese
zwei Interfaces, entweder den HomePod
mit Sprache oder die Fernbedienung, die eigentlich
immer an der Wand klebt.
Also die nehme ich gar nicht mal mit.
Die hat bloß den netten Vorteil, weil wir
im Wohnzimmer ist der einzige Raum, wo wenn du
durch die Tür gehst, die Lichtschalter rechts
statt links sind. Und dadurch, dass die Kehrvermögen
links ist, ist es schön einheitlich.
Mein Kopf kann das
besser einfach direkt hier gar
nicht darauf denken, sondern links greifen.
Bevor ich das gemacht hatte, hatte ich einige,
ich mag hier keine Deckenlampen, deswegen habe ich so
Stehlampen dann mit solchen billigen
Rankforce
Funksteckdosen ausgestattet
und habe dann einfach
in der Küche und
in der Eingangstür jeweils eine von diesen
Fernbedienungen mit Paterfix an die Wand geklebt.
Warum nicht? Und das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Musst du bloß bei den vier Klöpfen merken,
welcher der richtige ist?
Ja, es sind ja bloß vier.
Ja, an und aus.
Ja, du hast jeweils einen an und jeweils einen aus.
Achso, direktierte an-aus-Klöpfe.
Ich meine, du kannst hier hinten noch irgendwie zwischen Gruppen hin und her
sein. Und ich wollte auch
eigentlich von diesen, also der einzige
Grund, warum ich mir diese Ikea-Lampen gekauft
habe, war, weil ich von diesen Rank-4
Dingern weggehen wollte. Achso.
Denn ich habe irgendwie irgendwann
den Eindruck gehabt, dass ich angegriffen werde.
Erstens,
das ist ein total triviales Funksystem,
diese Dinger. Ich kaufe mir das,
das hat irgendwie vier Knöpfe und
vier Gruppen, das heißt, du hast maximal
16 unterschiedliche Kanäle.
Glücklicherweise benutzt
in dem Haus da und in diesem Haus hier unten
drunter oder nebenan
niemand solche Fernbedienungen. Sonst würden
wir uns damit gegenseitig ärgern.
Was ich allerdings schon hatte, ist, dass ich abends
gekommen bin und in meinem Schlafzimmer das Licht an war.
Und ich mich gewundert habe,
fast zum Geier. Dann habe ich überlegt, dann wirst du da paranoid.
Also wenn du jemanden
angreifen willst, gehst du mit so einer Fernbedienung durch die Gegend.
Also angreifen. Insofern, dass du
durch die Gegend gehst. Erstens kannst du die Leute ärgern,
das Licht an- und ausmachen. Kannst du aber auch einfach
bei Leuten das Licht
anmachen und schauen, ob es am nächsten Tag aus ist.
Ob sie checken, ob die
im Urlaub sind als Einbrecher.
Der Klassiker. So, und dann bin ich dann immer mal
spätnachts nach Hause gekommen und in meinem Schlafzimmer
war das Licht an. Und ich denke mir so, warum?
bis mir irgendwann mal, als ich
Montagmorgens relativ früh aufgewacht
bin, aufgefallen ist,
dass irgendwie mein Schlafzimmerlicht angeht, wenn gerade
das Müllauto draußen vorbeifahren.
Weil die offenbar irgendeine Steuerung,
mit der sie
vielleicht irgendwie hinten die Kübel
hochfahren oder sowas,
das selbe Signal
wie die Fernbedienung, die bei mir im Schlafzimmer ist.
Das ist ja auch ein fantastischer Zufall.
Das ist super geil. Seitdem weiß ich, dass
irgendwie bei mir das Licht angeht, wenn das Müllauto
da ist.
Spannend.
Größeres Ziel wäre schon,
diese normalen, einfachen Funkgeschichten
komplett abzulösen.
Aber das ist immer noch das Angenehmste.
Also mit App,
das Licht die ganze Zeit steuern ist nervig.
Das will ich auch nicht mehr machen,
weil das halt viel zu mühsam ist.
Meine Erfahrung mit den Ikea-Fernbedienungen ist,
dass die auch relativ schnell alle sind.
Okay, ich bin bisher einmal alle gewesen.
Man könnte Home Assistant
oder das Ikea-Zeugs
an so einen Home Assistant,
an so einen Sprachassistenten anschließen.
Das will ich aber auch nicht.
Man will nicht die ganze Zeit reden mit seinem Licht, das ist dämlich.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, macht das Licht an oder sowas,
aber ich hab nur so einen scheiß Alexa-Denk.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die HomePods das machen.
Dann hast du halt Credentials für was
in deinem Haus irgendwo bei Amazon in der Cloud liegen.
Will ich eigentlich nicht.
Also angeblich läuft das alles in meinem Haus.
Ich mein gut, vertraue ich Apple an der Stelle.
Bei Apple kann ich mir das eher vorstellen.
Bei Amazon ist es definitiv in der Cloud.
Und dann hast du quasi wieder,
das Schöne an dem Home Assistant ist halt,
das Ding läuft komplett bei mir im Haus.
Ich hab's auch nicht ans Internet freigegeben.
Das habe ich schon überlegt, auch das zusammen mit dem NAS.
Aber die Zeit habe ich mir noch nicht nehmen können,
um das wirklich zu konfigurieren.
Verständlich.
Ansonsten fände ich es schon nice, über die Fritzbox geht das.
Also meine zwei Lampen und meine Thermostate
kann ich auch über die Fritzbox steuern.
Und da komme ich von unterwegs ran.
Könnte ich jetzt irgendwie eine Lampe von zu Hause an machen
oder gucken, wie warm es in meinem Wohnzimmer ist.
Man findet es immer ganz cool, aber Bedarf hat man dann auch eher wenig.
Ein bisschen Quatsch.
Ist auch ein bisschen Quatsch.
Insofern. Ich weiß nicht, was
sagen denn unsere Zuhörer dazu?
Was für Use Cases kennt ihr noch
schöne dafür,
dass man
über das Internet von außerhalb
seine
Home-Automatisierung steuern könnte?
Sei es nur Licht oder Heizung oder
Blenden oder...
Auch mal interessant. Schreibt uns das mal bitte.
Mein Dad ist auch großer Fan von sowas, nutzt das schon
seit vielen, vielen Jahren und wir haben
zu Hause auch schon länger so Dinger gehabt,
dass wenn jemand
das Fenster aufmacht, dass die Heizung automatisch
ausgeht und so. Das finde ich tatsächlich
recht clever an der Stelle, aber da gibt es
nicht viel Use Cases auch, um Dinge von
außen zu machen. Er hat noch jetzt
mittlerweile auch schon wieder ein bisschen her, aber
da bin ich schon längst nicht mehr da gewesen, eine Kamera
im Wohnzimmer stehen, auf die er von außen
zugreifen kann und die ihm automatisch
kurze Videos schickt, wenn Bewegungen
erkannt werden, wenn sie nicht da waren.
Was ein bisschen witzig ist, weil sonst kriegt er
jedes Mal eine E-Mail mit dem Video-Ausschnitt, wenn der
Roomba durch die Wohnung gefahren ist.
Wow, das ist ja richtig ein Mehrwert hier.
Das kriegst du aber selber gebaut. Es gibt ein Linux-Tool,
das heißt Motion oder so ähnlich.
Und das macht einfach deine Webcam an
und da kannst du irgendwelche
Heuristiken einstellen und sagen, wenn sich davor was bewegt,
dann speichere ich still da.
Es gibt auch immer wieder dieses Projekt,
das immer wieder mal hochkommt auf Hacker News,
von diesen alten Android-Geräten zu
Überwachungsgeräten für daheim
und funktionieren. Auch nicht schlecht, ja.
Ich hätte auch überlegt, ob ich ein altes Tablet einfach mit diesem
Home Assistant Interface irgendwo
hinstelle und das einfach so als Lichtschalter benutze.
Ah, da musst du da Strom hinlegen.
So wirklich Bedarf habe ich dafür auch nicht.
Bei mir ist wirklich alles
an Smart Home-Kfuh, es sind diese drei Lampen,
die an der Decke im Wohnzimmer hängen.
Witziges Ding, was ich auch ein bisschen nervig
finde daran, ist, dass diese Ikea-Fernbedienung
die sendet halt wirklich bloß so ein Toggle-Befehl.
Und das dann an alle Geräte.
Sprich, wenn ich manchmal auch nur
eine Lampe anmache, die auf den Schreibtisch zeigt
zum Beispiel. Weil du die zusammen gepaert hast, meinst du?
Die sind gepaert mit allen drei Lampen im Wohnzimmer.
Das ist dann komisch.
Das ist bei mir bei dieser Lampe da so und meine Deckenlampe,
die hat dann auch warmes und kaltes Licht
und wenn die Lampen untereinander eine unterschiedliche Farbe haben,
dann passt das nicht.
Das kriegst du aber hin, wenn du dir so ein IKEA Gateway holst.
Wir sind gerade heute voll die Werbesendung.
So ein Gateway habe ich auch, aber das macht halt nichts damit,
weil die Fernbedienung kommuniziert nicht über den Gateway,
die Fernbedienung kommuniziert direkt mit den Lampen,
aber andere Dinge kommunizieren über den Gateway mit den Lampen.
Aber wenn du die App hast, kannst du dir...
Ich habe die App angefasst.
Ich habe die installiert zum Eindrichtung.
Damit kannst du zumindest das Gerät
unterschiedlichen Gruppen von Geräten zuweisen.
Du pairst eigentlich dann das Gerät,
die Fernbedienung einmal mit dem Gateway
und danach kannst du
einstellen...
Ach, da sind diese Pfeiltasten der Fernbedienung dafür da,
dass ich dann zwischen den Gruppen umscheiden kann?
Nee, nee, nee, nicht Gruppen. Du hast dann irgendwie
schon fest diese Fernbedienung
im Gerät zugeordnet.
Die Pfeiltasten links und rechts
sind, um hier zwischen warm und kalt hinunterzusehen.
Achso, das können die Lammen bei mir nicht.
Die können bloß dimmen.
Was ich auch richtig sinnlos finde,
Freundin von mir, ich sag keinen Namen,
war ich zu Weihnachten zu Besuch,
die hatte sich für
300 Euro Philips Hue Lampen geholt
und war super Fan davon, dass sie sich jetzt
hier zwei Strahler und da eine Lampe und da
eine Deckenleuchte und sowas angebaut hatte
und dann hat sie auch wie gesagt, ja, ich kann
hier zwischen unterschiedlichen
Farben, die hat da richtig krass die Farben
gewechselt, die hatte mal ein bisschen beige an
oder langscht oder
türkis oder blau
oder gelb und fand das schön und ich dachte
mir so, das ist super kitschig, das
könnte ich nie machen. Also das krasseste
Gegen farbiges Licht habe ich nichts einzuwenden.
Das kann schon ein echt schönes Theme mitbringen.
Aber es sieht immer unnatürlich aus.
Es sieht dann immer aus wie auf dem Jahrmarkt.
Ja, kommt drauf an, wie du es machst.
Und es gibt einen
Ich bin sehr empfindlich, was Licht angeht.
Es gibt einen sichtbaren Unterschied zwischen
farbigem LED-Licht
und weißem Licht mit einem farbigen Filter drüber.
Also, was so...
Ich habe so eine
Spaßlampe, also ich lehne das ab,
deswegen habe ich sie nicht zu Hause, aber ich habe es seit Jahren
so eine
so eine farbige LED mit so einer
Fernbedienung mal gehabt und du siehst halt,
dass das nicht, du hast nicht,
du kannst dir so ein Lichtspektrum vorstellen,
es gibt auch diese Spektrallinien, wo du
irgendwo siehst, wenn du so
von Sternen licht, wo die Löcher
sind, wo du erkennst, welche
Elemente da drin sind und so weiter.
Bei einem, wenn du
so einen farbigen Filter vornimmst,
aus einem weißen Licht, dann filterst
du ein Subset raus und der
Rest ist immer noch komplett da. Bei LEDs
ist es andersrum, da hast du wirklich nur
das bisschen roter Teil, das bisschen grüner Teil.
Bei einem grünen Farbfilter filterst du alles bis auf...
Nee, nicht alles, aber du filterst...
Genau, bei einem grünen Farbfilter filterst du alles bis auf so einen gewissen Grünbereich
und bei einer grünen LED hast du wirklich nur grünes Licht.
Und das macht eine wesentlich härtere Kante.
Dadurch verändern sich Farben von Gegenständen, die du beleuchtest.
Interessant.
Viel krasser.
Und das...
Also, das kann man schön finden.
Ich finde es nicht schön.
Was noch dazu kommt, ist, dass die meisten LED-Lampen irgendwie so subtil flackern.
Das merke ich irgendwie auch.
Es gibt die Dinger, die
mehr flackern als andere, das stimmt.
Also ich habe hier unten diese, also nochmal was,
was natürlich jetzt nichts für unsere Zuhörer ist,
aber ich habe hier diese hornalte Lichterkette
am Rand liegen, die so ein bisschen subtil ist,
die wird auch immer kaputter.
Ihr könnt es nicht sehen gerade, aber die leuchtet
im, also die soll
nur gelb leuchten, habe ich das Gefühl.
Die sollte mal weiß leuchten, aber es sind auch schon so einige rote Lampen
und so einige schwarze Lampen dabei.
Das ist ein gefühltes Riesenspektrum.
Die hatte ich immer ersetzt.
Ich fand das einfach schön, so ein
Ambient Light auf Bodenhöhe
zu haben, gerade weil es hier an der Wand entlang geht,
ist nur mit dem
Ding leider nicht mehr gegeben. Dann habe ich mal einen Ersatz
gekauft dafür. Das Ding
hier ist halt 15
Jahre alt. Das habe ich irgendwann mal bei meinen Eltern aus dem Keller
geklaut. Das war so eine Außen...
So alt wie eine Idee.
Und das gibt es nur noch
mit LED. Das hier sind irgendwelche kleinen, konventionellen
Birnen. Und
die LED-Sachen, die strahlen nicht
rundum. Die strahlen in eine Richtung. Das heißt,
du hast diesen Schlauch und da strahlt man nach da und macht nach da.
Das ist ja dumm.
Und es ist viel zu kalt und es flackert.
Ich habe es dann auf dem Kongress irgendwie auf den Tisch gelegt.
Da habe ich es um den Tisch drum herum gelegt
und dann war es irgendwie,
zwei Tage später war es auch schon die Hälfte von dieser Leiste kaputt,
weil es irgendwie durch das Knicken gebrochen ist.
Die LED-Leisten, die ich in meine Tasche gebastelt hatte für den Kongress,
was da wunderbar funktioniert hatte, mit der Powerbank in der Tasche drin,
die sind leider auch wieder kaputt gegangen.
Wir haben auf dem Konkurs
eine von den dreien den Geist
aufgegeben, also blau ging nicht mehr
von den RGB-LEDs.
Keine Ahnung, ich glaube, bloß der Kontakt vorne irgendwo
broken. Das ist eventuell was, was man
vernachlässigt. Also wir haben jetzt schöne neue LED-Welt
und jeder macht es überall hin, aber an und für sich
es ist ein Wegwerfprodukt,
was sehr viel Elektroschrott produziert.
Ja, billigelektroniges
Wegwerfschrott.
Habe ich das Gefühl, mehr.
Und es verleitet halt
mehr dazu, billige Produkte zu machen.
ist zumindest jetzt meine
Vermutung erstmal. Naja,
genug Werbung hier für Ikea und
Kogel. Ja, also wenn ihr
solche Geräte schon habt, wenn es nicht Ikea ist
oder irgendwas anderes ist, irgendwas, das
sich gefühlt nach IoT
anhört oder anriecht,
dann schaut euch doch mal,
das ist jetzt Werbung für ein nicht
kommerzielles Produkt, schaut euch mal Home Assistant an,
weil man damit wahrscheinlich das, was ihr habt, auch
fernsteuern kann. Das ist einfach krass,
wie viele Anschlüsse
die das Zeug hat? Das kann wirklich alles.
Home Assistant hat sogar einen eigenen Podcast.
Oha, okay. Es gibt den Home Assistant
Podcast. Wie viele Open Source Projekte haben das denn?
Tja.
Krass.
Genau. Soviel zum Thema
Heimautomatisierung und
the lack thereof.
Nicht schlecht. Wie steht denn in der Themenliste?
Du hast mal wieder mit Ace & Crust rumgespielt.
Das heißt Ace & Crust, also
was heißt mal wieder?
Seit
Rustfest seit der vorletzten
Rust-Version, seit 39 oder
40, ist Async Await
endlich ein stabiles Sprachfeature.
Geiler Scheiß.
Und ich habe es lange vor mir hergeschoben,
mal mit Async Await in Rust rumzuspielen,
weil man sich plötzlich, also Async Await
hast du wahrscheinlich schon ein JavaScript in der Hand gehabt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es in Swift aussieht.
Gibt es nicht.
Also es war mal prognostiziert und von Chris Lettner
als Proposal, ohne
weitere Implementation
mal hingelegt, aber
es steht noch weit, weit weg.
In Rust ist ja da eine ziemliche Blüte
entstanden. Da gibt es irgendwie
Tokio, was es schon vorher gab für AsyncIO,
was es ziemlich
gut benutzt. Das gibt es hier von
der Firma von Florian Glicher, der hier
bereits zu Besuch war,
gibt es AsyncSTD.
Das wurde auf dem Rustfest auch
vorgestellt. Das sind quasi eine komplett...
AsyncSTUD.
Also
STD ist deutsch.
Das sagen nämlich die Deutschen
alleine zu diesem
Standard-Library-Prefix und
Amis sagen fast durchgängig std.
Also es gibt Async std.
Niemals, sag doch std.
Doch. Was?
Ja, so std-shared-pointer.
Was? Ja doch, std.
Nein. Weil std klingt
nach Geschichtskraft. Ja gut, std sagt doch,
aber Leute sagen doch standard oder so,
standard ausscheinert in, std in.
Anyway, es gibt
einige Projekte,
dass das Spannende an dem Thema ist,
oder das, was es ein bisschen kompliziert macht, ist, dass du halt deinen eigenen Executor mitbringen musst,
oder haben musst, der ist halt nicht Teil der Sprache.
In JavaScript sagst du einfach Promise und es geht los.
Oder du sagst einfach Await something und es geht los.
In Rust konfigurierst du solche Continuation Chains, kannst du entweder auch mit Send an einander chanen,
oder du hast Async Functions, wo du Await benutzen kannst.
Und die kannst du dann als Block,
und es gibt demnächst hoffentlich auch,
das ist noch nicht fertig,
Async-Closures,
aber die musst du dann quasi als Task
in einem Executor ausführen.
Okay.
Das geht.
Das kannst du halt entweder manuell machen.
Machst du häufig nicht manuell,
was viele von den Frameworks,
die Exekutoren mitbringen.
Actix ist eins,
Async-Stud ist eins,
Tokio ist eins.
Was die machen, ist, dass die dir
ein Main-Makro
mitbringen. Das heißt, du kannst
bei Tokyo oder
bei AsyncStud kannst du
TokyoMain oder AsyncMain
als Annotation
an deine Main-Funktion ranschreiben
und dann hast du plötzlich,
dann erzeugt das für dich eine andere Main-Funktion
und deine Main-Funktion wird
dann darin aufgeführt, das nimmt dir einfach so ein ganzes
Stück Boilerplate weg, wo du sagst,
erzeug mir einen Executor und schmeißt da die erste
Task rein. Das heißt, deine Main-Funktion
bereits eine Async-Funktion und du kannst da drin
direkt Sex machen. Und ich hab damit
so ein bisschen... Ich hab noch nicht viel gemacht.
Ich hab's endlich mal...
Ich bin ein bisschen auf die Fresse geflogen,
weil ich bei dem
Rust-Meetup im November
endlich mal mit Leuten drüber reden wollte.
Und dann
war's... Ach, das ist ja, im November war ich
auch in Barcelona. Genau.
Und da waren die Leute,
die da zu Besuch waren, kannten sich teilweise besser aus.
Und jetzt hab ich endlich mal ein kleines Projekt gemacht, wo ich
Async-Rate in Rust verwendet habe.
Und es ist ziemlich, wenn man
angefangen hat damit, ist es eigentlich
ziemlich nice, wenn man
vor allem sich mit Exekutoren
und sowas schon ein bisschen auseinandergesetzt hat.
Man muss plötzlich Begriffe
kennen, die man in JavaScript nicht kennen muss.
Es gibt ja auch ein bisschen größeren Hürder als in anderen
Sprachen, wo es das Konzept gibt, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, dadurch, dass es halt, es gibt
quasi Co-Routines in der Sprache,
also als
Async-Funktion,
aber derjenige, der diese
Tasks, die du dann aufbaust,
für dich ausführt, der wird dir von der
Sprache nicht als
Intrinsic mitgegeben, sondern
das ist einfach, du kannst so eine
Task konfigurieren und wenn du auf
einer Async-Funktion beim Ausführen
nicht Await sagst, dann wird die halt
nicht ausgeführt.
Das musst du halt plötzlich lernen.
Krass.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich wieder
ein bisschen tief für einen Podcast.
Wie gesagt, ich kenne mich auch noch nicht super
damit aus, aber ich hatte letzte Woche
einen Workshop bei mir
auf Arbeit gemacht.
Rust for Beginners und der zweite
Teil war Just Enough Rust to be Dangerous.
Da habe ich
einfach für den ersten Teil die Slides
von Rustbridge
verwendet. Das ist auch so eine kleine Community, die sich
darauf spezialisiert, Rust zu unterrichten.
Das waren sehr gute Slides.
Die habe ich ein bisschen aufgebohrt,
weil ich wusste, dass ich
diesen Vortrag vornehmlich von C++-Entwicklern
halten werde, habe ich ein paar Grundlagen
rausgeschmissen und noch ein paar
Higher Level Sachen oder ein bisschen tiefere Sachen
mit reingenommen. Da wollte ich ursprünglich
die ersten drei Stunden vormittags und die zweiten
drei Stunden nachmittags machen.
Mussten dann allerdings, weil wir einen Termin
hatten, nachmittags, der spontan reinkam,
den zweiten Teil verschieben.
Und das war auch ganz gut, weil die Leute
haben nach den ersten drei Stunden schon so ein bisschen geächtzt.
Und das hat super Spaß gemacht.
Da habe ich aber zum Beispiel Acing Away komplett
ausgespart, weil es einfach nochmal
ein ganz anderes Fass aufgemacht hat.
Und für,
wenn ihr mal Lust habt,
mit Rust rumzuspielen und euch die
Fingersprutze zu machen, es gibt
Rustlings. Das war ein schönes Projekt, was ich den
Leuten so als Übung gegeben habe. Das war richtig,
auch aus der Rustbridge-Community gab es das dazu.
Das ist ein Projekt,
es ist wie Exorcism quasi.
Du hast so einen kleinen Watcher,
den du startest und der versucht, alle Exercises
zu kompilieren. Die kompilieren aber alle
nicht. Und dann musst du halt der Reihe
nach irgendwelche kleinen Fehler und irgendwelche kleinen Programmen
beheben. Und das führt einen eigentlich
durch einige Ecken der
Sprache, die man dadurch ganz gut ausprobieren
kann. Und das
Wichtigste, was ich hinterher festgestellt habe, ist, dass
man, wenn man Leuten eine neue Sprache beibringen
möchte, dann muss man
nicht unbedingt die Sprache selber vermitteln,
sondern alles andere.
Also das Wichtigste, worauf
ich hingewiesen habe, oder wo die Leute gesagt haben,
es ist gut, dass du das gesagt hast, war,
es gibt eine umfangreiche
Standard-Bibliotheks-Dokumentation, die liegt
dort. Dort steht auch alles drin,
was man rundum braucht. Modul-Level-
Dokumentation in Rust erklärt dir sogar,
was der Unterschied zwischen der List
und dem Deck ist oder wie
Hash-Maps und B-Tree-Maps und so
sich verhalten mit
sehr viel Fließtext.
Gibt es seit kurzem auch eine schöne
Vanity-Domain
std.rs
Leitet einen direkt
zur Standard-Library-Dokumentation um.
Ich gefühlt, dieser TLD wird doch komplett
im Schlag genommen von den WAS-Leuten.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Genau, das war
so mit das Wichtigste. Und einfach so Seiten
aufzählen, wo man Informationen findet,
dass die Angst vor dem Compiler
nehmen, weil Leute gerade, die C++ machen,
Tümmel, die gehen mit einer ganz anderen
Wartezeit. Also wenn du C++ machst,
dann liest du eigentlich die Compilerfehler
nicht mehr wirklich. Entweder du bist so gut geworden,
dass du sie wirklich kannst. Ich meine,
ich will jetzt nichts unterstellen, die Leute kriegen das auch hin.
Aber ich zum Beispiel, wenn ich ab und zu mal
wieder C++ mache,
wenn ich sehe, es kompiliert nicht,
dann gucke ich kurz auf die 5 Meter
Text, die mir da gerade hingeprintet wurden,
stelle fest, das hilft mir jetzt überhaupt nicht
und starre dann lieber
nochmal auf die letzten 10 Zeilen, die ich
angefasst habe.
Und das ist bei Rust halt komplett anders.
Also das ist tatsächlich sogar so,
was jetzt auch noch passiert ist in dem Zeitraum, ist
das VS Code Add-on,
was bislang so das
gängigste war, dieses RLS, Rust Language
Service, das ist jetzt beerbt
durch Rust Analyzer,
was auch aus der Community entwickelt
wird, auch von hier
Florians Firma mit
unterstützt, von einem ehemaligen
C-Line-Entwickler
oder JetBrains-Mitarbeiter.
Und das Ding ist richtig geil
geworden. Das zeigt dir,
das macht das in deinem
Outline-View richtig, die
Hierarchie von deinem Programm
anständig dargestellt wird. Das konnte
RLS
nicht. Es macht wunderschöne
ziemlich schnelle, effiziente
Recompile-Zyklen, dass du was tippst und der
relativ schnell erkennt, wo
da ein Fehler ist. Autocompletion funktioniert super.
Ich habe das ausgetauscht.
Ich war kurz davor, bei dem Workshop
den Leuten zu sagen,
nehmt es mal noch nicht, ist noch nicht fertig.
Tag vorher kam es, gut, man kann es jetzt
über den Extension Store installieren.
Man muss das vorher irgendwie selber manuell installieren.
Nö, nö, die Binary wird jetzt runtergeladen.
Wenn ihr euch diese Extension installiert,
dann aktualisiert sie auch von alleine.
Ist ganz super. Und dann habe ich Leuten gesagt, gut,
dann installiert halt das und es ging absolut dufter.
Also damit ist VS Code jetzt eine richtig
geile Rust-ID geworden.
Voll gut. Ich meine, so Tooling ist,
also gutes Tooling ist echt so ein schönes
Ding.
Das bräuchte ich gerne auch mal
anderswo bitte mehr.
Kann man eigentlich Swift mit VS Code entwickeln?
Ja, also es gibt tatsächlich den
Swift Language Server Plugin. Das macht
letztendlich genau das, bloß halt
bei Weib nicht so gut wie Rust,
aber es macht trotzdem ganz gut.
Kommt offiziell auch mit von Apple.
also es ist supported
und läuft wunderbar, also gerade wenn du
kleinere Dinge machst, die
beziehungsweise auf der Plattform bist, die zwar
eine Swift-Toolchain hat, aber kein Xcode, dann ist
das eigentlich dein Way to go.
Und bis vor kurzem war das auch für Swift-Packages
halt das angenehmste, weil Xcode dafür
bedingt Support hatte.
Swift-Packages gehen jetzt in Xcode sehr gut
dafür, wenn du jetzt hier ein One-Off-Script
hast, ohne Package drumherum,
wo einfach nur eine Swift-Datei
die du ausführst, einfach so hier
Stimmt, man kann es ja auch ein bisschen wie eine Skript-Sprache.
Es hat so einen Interpreted Mode.
Der witzige ist, ich habe letztens erst ein Tool
für unser Projekt auf Arbeit geschrieben.
Ich wollte, das hat angefangen damit hier,
ich wollte einfach mal ungenutzte Übersetzungen
aus unseren Übersetzungsdateien rauslöschen.
Weil hier Code löscht man hin und wieder,
Übersetzungsdüngstück löscht man nicht,
weil denkt da keine Sau dran.
Habe ich angefangen, die zu löschen.
Irgendwann dachte ich mir, das ist viel zu viel manuelle Arbeit.
Da schreibe ich jetzt ein Localization-Datei-Lint dafür.
Dann haben wir jetzt ein kleines Skript,
was bei jedem Bauen ausgeführt wird.
Das ist ein Swift-Skript, was da drüber schaut
und diverse Lints ausgibt.
ob das jetzt eine leere String ist,
der in der Besetzung drinsteckt, ob die Übersetzung
identisch zu einer anderen Sprache ist,
mit ein paar Whitelists wie
okay und so
und diverse andere Sachen.
Unter anderem macht das halt jetzt auch dann
schaut nach, ob die in Code benutzt werden.
Was leider echt nicht so trivial war,
also ich kriege es nicht hin, dass das schnell ist,
aber zu diesem Fall habe ich dafür
ein Zwift-Skript geschrieben, was halt bei jedem Bauen
in diesem Interpreted-Mode ausgeführt wird.
Das würde ich gerade fragen,
wie kann ich diesen Interpreted-Mode verstehen?
Ich meine, im Endeffekt ist Swift trotzdem eine LLVM-kombinierte Sprache.
Ja, es wird trotzdem gebaut, aber es hat ein paar witzige Nebeneffekte, wie zum Beispiel...
Wie ist da die Startup-Time? Dauert es dann 10 Sekunden?
Nee, es geht tatsächlich relativ flink.
Du hast halt aktuell keine Möglichkeit, sowas wie Dependencies reinzuziehen.
Da gibt es zwei Workarounds für.
Der eine Workaround ist, ein Projekt namens Swift Shell zu benutzen,
was dann on the fly quasi daraus ein Package macht, die Dependencies reinzieht,
die oben am Import-Statement über einen Kommentar einfach mitsteht.
dahinter, wo kommt das Package her, da kannst du
einfach zum Beispiel, du hast einen Import-Package-Name,
dahinter ein Kommentar und dann einfach
nur ein GitHub-Username, Add-Username
und dann ist halt die einfachste
Syntax davon, dann schaut er halt,
das ist ein Add-Zeichen, muss GitHub sein,
Username, Slash, der Import und holt sich
davon die letzte Version, was ziemlich schicke
für den einfachsten Case-Syntax
ist, aber da gibt es natürlich komplexere Möglichkeiten,
um alles abzudecken, das ist der eine Workaround.
Der andere ist der, der noch nicht existiert,
aber aktuell proposed ist,
nämlich, dass man so einen Property-Wrapper
was ja keine Property ist, dann, dass du zum Beispiel
add package vor den Import schreibst
und da dann den Klammern angibst, wo das herkommt.
Das soll ein Zwift-Schein-Normal-End-Feature werden
und dann ist es möglich,
das darüber zu machen. Aber das gibt es noch nicht,
das ist aktuell nur proposed.
Bei Rust hat sich ja, was Imports angeht,
seit mit der 2018er-Version
ein bisschen was verändert,
dass du, vorher musstest du am Anfang von deiner Datei,
eigentlich deiner Main-Datei,
immer dieses
extern-create-Pile.
Das fand ich immer weird. Ich habe das nie wirklich richtig verstanden,
muss ich sagen.
Ich fand das eigentlich ganz schick, weil das sagt hier, welche Crates du wirklich, welche externen Crates du wirklich benutzt. Das war so ein Hinweis an den Linker.
Das war so doppelt gemoppelt, so ein richtig wettes Ding, was ich nochmal doppelt reinziehen muss.
Du hast es dir in deine Cargo-Tammel reingeschrieben, damit Cargo dir das runterlädt und mit ranlinkt. Und dann hast du es in deine Main-Datei reingeschrieben, damit der Compiler beim Kompilieren weiß, dass er das mitverwenden soll.
Ja, und warum?
Es war nicht wirklich konsistent,
weil es hat gleichzeitig gemacht,
dass das Ding in dein Namespace geladen wurde.
Es hat also das Gleiche gemacht wie ein Use auch noch.
Eben, du hast ja trotzdem auch noch gebraucht, das Use.
Nee, das Use hast du dann in der Datei nicht gebraucht,
aber in der anderen vielleicht.
Das war verwirrend.
Das war mir gar nicht so bewusst,
als mich da jemand drauf hingewiesen hat.
Ah, stimmt, das macht irgendwie zwei unterschiedliche Sachen.
Deswegen haben sie es rausgeworfen.
Finde ich gut.
So, jetzt sagst du nur noch Use irgendwas
oder manchmal sagst du überhaupt nicht mehr Use,
wenn du nur noch aus dem Namespace was verwendest
und es steht nur noch in deiner Cargo-Tommel.
Aber irgendwie finde ich das auch nicht so richtig schön,
weil dann,
jetzt schreibst du vor alles, was lokal ist,
Crate davor.
Es gibt irgendwie,
du sagst nochmal Use, dann kommt Crate
und dann dein Modul oder direkt eine Funktion
oder sowas. Du kannst zum Beispiel in deine,
es gibt ein schönes Ding,
das heißt Color Backtrace,
das funktioniert als
Backtrace-Catcher und macht dir einen bunteren
Backtrace draus, der lesbarer ist.
als der native.
Und da sagst du einfach bloß
cargo add, dann steht es in deiner
cargo-Tommel drin und dann sagst du in deiner
Main nur noch color backtrace
install. Du musst es
nicht usen, weil der
Namespace ist vorne dran und da
weißt du, dass es das install aus dem
Root von dem anderen Crate verwenden soll.
Es geht.
Aber so Modulsysteme sind immer noch
ich wollte nämlich gerade noch
nochmal
reinkrätschen hier, weil ich mich seit der letzten Folge
mal mit Dino nochmal auseinandergesetzt hatte.
Hast du dir mal Dino angeguckt?
Was war das nochmal?
Das ist Node rückwärts.
Nee.
Wolltest du noch was zu Swift sagen?
Es ist doch Edon, oder?
Bin ich gerade doof im Kopf?
Ja, es ist einfach die beiden Silben umgedreht.
Achso, okay.
Mal kurz den Stack anwinden bei Swift.
Der Interpreted Mode hat diesen witzigen Quirk zum Beispiel,
dass du Funktionen deklarieren musst,
bevor sie sie benutzt. Das heißt, die müssen alle oben
in der Datei stehen, was ein bisschen weird ist.
Weil sie wird ja trotzdem gebaut, aber irgendwie
anders gebaut.
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, warum
alles die unterschiedlich sind.
Dann wird irgendwo eine gebaute Version gecached?
Die wird auf jeden Fall gecached, weil
die läuft schneller beim nächsten Mal.
Aber ich bin mir überhaupt
nicht sicher, wie das da alles läuft.
Aber es läuft auf jeden Fall schnell genug,
dass man das auch hier
in den Kaltstart machen kann damit.
Also bedeutend unter einer Sekunde,
Und würdest du Swift dementsprechend vornehmlich, wenn du jetzt nicht gerade Code aus deinem anderen Swift-Code damit lesen oder analysieren wollen, würdest du Swift vornehmlich dann als Skriptsprache?
Ich würde Zig mal lieber als Bash benutzen.
Das ist gar keine Frage.
Zig ist übrigens auch eine Sprache.
Naja.
Nee, es gibt so ein komisches Ding,
das ist in der iOS-Welt zum Beispiel
vor allem sehr beliebt ist für
Bildautomatisierung und Skripto und jeglichen
Kram, Ruby zu benutzen.
Ich weiß nicht, wo das herkommt.
Wir haben auf Arbeit gerade ganz viel
Ruby-Code weggeschmissen. Ja, ich finde das
an sich ist Ruby eine schöne Sprache.
Was mir sehr missfällt an der Sache, ist, dass
es jedem aufgeheimst wird, das Ruby-Environment
mitzumanagen. Und ein Ruby-Environment ist so
ekelhaft zu managen. Genau.
Da kann ich echt
länger drüber ranten, aber
ich persönlich mag es sehr, wenn du,
also, dass ich, wenn ich eh
in Projekten bin, wo ich in der Sprache schreibe,
dass ich auch die Tools, die drumherum
liegen, in der Sprache mitschreiben kann.
Das ist aber ein neuer Trend.
Das ist ein Trend auf jeden Fall. Das war früher nicht so.
Dann lass mich mal kurz was zu Dino erzählen.
Okay, gerne. Also, du kennst
Node.js. Ja. Ich erzähl mal
kurz für die Leute, die jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt
super familiar sind mit Node.js, aber Node.js
ist eine Runtime für JavaScript.
Da hat sich der Ryan Dahl vor
zehn Jahren... Bestimmt auch so alt wie die
Wii.
Nicht ganz so alt wie die Wii wahrscheinlich, aber ich glaube
Node.js, kannst du mir nachgucken. Aber der hat sich zumindest
irgendwann gedacht, ja, ich möchte auch Shell-Skripte und Web-Server
mit JavaScript schreiben können.
2009, vor zehn Jahren. Ah ja, doch.
Und da hat er einfach quasi
LibUV, was auch so eine
asynchrone Runtime oder asynchrone
I.O. Library ist für
File-System und Netzwerkzeugs.
Einfach mit
V8 aus dem Chrome zusammengestellt.
und zack, gab es Node.js.
Finde ich auch geil, was für eine simple Idee eigentlich das Ganze ist
und was daraus geworden ist.
Ja, und das Problem an der Sache war,
dass viele konkrete Probleme,
die du beim Erzeugen einer neuen Programmiersprache schaffst
und lösen musst.
Bei Node, weil es damals,
weil es erst 2009 war und nicht 2015 oder sowas,
war dann halt ein Afterthought,
dass du irgendwie Pakete managen möchtest,
dass du eine Package.json brauchst.
wo du deine Dependencies hinlegst.
Der hat ja selber gesagt,
wir
tun uns irgendwelche Dependencies rein,
wo tun wir die rein? Node-Modules.
Wie Node-Module aufgelöst werden,
wie Dependencies reingezogen werden, wie die
paketiert installiert werden, wie man
Skripte ausführt, auf was so eine
Library auch zugreifen kann.
Wenn du JavaScript in deinem Browser ausführst,
worauf kann das JavaScript zugreifen
bei dir? Auf nichts.
Also du kannst Netzwerk-Requests
nur auf
deinen eigenen Server machen
oder auf Sachen, die sich von deinem Skript, von deiner
Webseite aus über Cores auch aufrufen
lassen. Das gleiche gilt für Websockets.
Es kann nicht auf dein Dateisystem zugreifen.
Wie paar Browser-APIs und das war's.
Geht wirklich nicht. Bei Node.js kann JavaScript
auf deine Dateisysteme. Der Node.js läuft ja auch in einem
anderen Kontext, klar. Genau.
Das ist ja auch nicht im Web. So, wenn du dir jetzt
allerdings ein Skript schreibst,
in Rust oder in Swift,
wo du auf dein Dateisystem
zugreifst und du führst das in
WESMA aus und du möchtest
irgendwie eine Datei lesen, dann
sagt dir das, nö, die Datei gibt es nicht.
Du musst bei WESMA beim Ausführen
sagen, gib dem mal noch Zugriff auf diesen Ordner,
damit dein Skript darauf zugreifen kann.
Und wenn du ein Netzwerk machen möchtest,
dann geht das auch nicht, es sei denn, du hast das
bei WESMA mit dem, oder bei irgendeiner
anderen WebAssembly Runtime,
es sei denn, du hast es mit einem
Flag gestartet, wo du sagst,
das darf auf
Netzwerk, File System oder Environment-Variation
zugreifen. Ansonsten sind die wirklich komplett gesandboxt.
Das ist so das Versprechen von
WebAssembly für
CE, C++, Rust,
Swift, alles was nach WebAssembly kompiliert.
Bei JavaScript kannst du das nicht machen. Bei JavaScript
hast du eine Sandbox, wenn du es im Browser ausführst
und du hast eine Sandbox,
nee, du hast keine Sandbox, wenn du es
in Node ausführst. Der Node-Skript kann
jederzeit alle Dateien lesen und dein
Environment lesen und das irgendwie an irgendeinen russischen
Pornoserver schicken oder
sowas.
Wenn dann ordentliche Leute, also ordentliche
Hacker, die Dinge müssen...
Ich habe mir gerade überlegt, was ist das
Shadieste, was mir einfallen würde.
Anyway, so, und irgendwie hat
sich auch Ryan Dahl, der vor
elf Jahren Node.js entwickelt hat,
gedacht, eigentlich haben wir da eine ganze Menge
Mist gemacht und der hat da irgendwie auf der
JSCon vor anderthalb Jahren einen Vortrag gehalten,
meine 10 Things that I regret about
Node.js. Und seitdem
arbeitet er an Dino.
Dino
ist
eine Runtime mit V8,
ja, er hat zwar ursprünglich
ein Go gebaut, jetzt mittlerweile ist es Rust,
unten drunter sitzt Tokio, das ist aber
nicht der Grund, warum ich reingeguckt habe, das waren
äh, es ist,
es baut
möglichst
webbiges JavaScript, also bei
Node.js hast du ja dieses Require, du hast
ein anderes Modulsystem, Modul Lookup
funktioniert unterschiedlich
und mittlerweile gibt es halt ECMAScript-Module
als Teil von JavaScript, also
wirklich, ähm, und
was Dino jetzt macht, das ist eine Runtime
und du sagst Dino auf ein TypeScript-Skript,
das nimmt das,
kompiliert das
und führt es für dich aus
und es wird gecached,
so wie wahrscheinlich auch bei evaluiertem Swift-Skripten.
Das heißt, du sagst Dino mein TypeScript,
also TypeScript ist doch die native Sprache von Dino.
Geil, sehr geil.
Dann kompiliert es das,
beim zweiten Mal ist es schneller,
weil es es irgendwo cached
und das Witzige ist jetzt,
wie Dino mit Dependencies umgeht.
Da bin ich, muss ich sagen, immer noch ein bisschen skeptisch,
aber interessant ist es, es macht es nämlich so ein bisschen wie Go.
Du hast keine Manifestdatei,
weil bei einem Webscript, wo du innerhalb von einem Browser
deinen Import sagst, hast du auch keine Manifestdatei.
Da sagst du Import this from HTTP so und so.
Um was aus der Standardbibliothek von Dino zu importieren,
sagst du, import
fuba from
https
www.dino.land
slash std slash irgendwas.
So jetzt hieß das von, also die
Bibliothek, die Standardbibliothek ist irgendwie
auch eine externe Dependency von
die bei Dino offiziell irgendwie rumliegt.
Die liegt auf dino.land.
Ich meine,
okay. Und die wird versioniert,
indem du slash std
at 036.0
Da sieht man wie alte Go-Dependencies über die URL.
Und es wird gecached,
nachdem du es das erste Mal ausgeführt hast.
Beim zweiten Mal ist es dementsprechend schneller.
Und du kannst deine Skripte,
und Dino ist dann nicht nur dein Ersatz für Node,
was ein TypeScript ausfüllt,
sondern es macht gleichzeitig,
du kannst es auch einfach checken,
du kannst es damit auch bundeln.
Das heißt, du kannst sagen,
zieh mir mal alle Dependencies
und mach mir ein Paket raus.
Du kannst es damit formatieren.
Ich glaube, du kannst damit auch Tests ausführen oder sowas.
also der hat relativ viele Learnings
aus anderen Sprachen mit reingenommen.
Die Modulstruktur
fühlt sich von der Standardbibliothek an,
fühlt sich so ein bisschen wie die Standardbibliothek von Rust.
Und
es ist eigentlich
super nice. Es ist komplett
inkompatibel mit Node.js, das heißt, du kannst
keine Node-Module oder
Node-Bibliotheken darin ausführen, einfach die
Namespaces
sich anders verhalten und du hast nicht
die Node-Standardbibliothek, also du kannst nicht auf die gleiche
Art und Weise Dateien öffnen
wie du in Node-Dateien öffnest.
Übrigens, du kannst auch keine Dateien öffnen,
es sei denn, du sagst Dino und dann gibst
einen Flag an, wo du erlaubst, dass
auf diese
Verzeichnisstruktur zugreifen kann.
Du könntest also Build-Skripte irgendwie damit
bauen, die wirklich nur auf deinen
Ordner zugreifen können und nicht irgendwie
dein... Das ist cool. Das ist echt check.
Und das ist alles noch,
der schreibt überall dran,
Vorsicht, alles experimentell, benutzt es noch
nicht und es ist auch immer noch so, dass
von Version zu Version Sachen kaputt gehen.
Also, weil sie einfach ständig
Breaking-API-Changes haben.
Aber ich finde es eigentlich ziemlich
spannend.
Dino hat ja auch selber,
das ist auch eine witzige Geschichte, Dino hat selber den TypeScript
Compiler eingebaut.
Wie hat es das gemacht?
Es nimmt den TypeScript Compiler-Code,
parsst den,
kompiliert den, um es auszuführen,
speichert dann aber das, was es da erzeugt hat,
das Kompilat.
als
das heißt V8 Snapshot.
Das heißt, wenn das V8
den TypeScript Compiler einmal im Speicher hat,
um ihn auszuführen, kannst du diesen Zustand
einfach irgendwo hinlegen und damit kommt quasi
Dino vor
konfiguriert mit. Das heißt,
die Startup Time ist dadurch extrem viel schneller.
Und das kannst du auch mit deinen eigenen Skripten machen.
Das heißt, du kannst sagen, ich schreibe ein Skript
und du kannst es zusammen mit Dino
als V8 Snapshot
shippen, das heißt,
du sparst dir diese höhere
Startup-Time von
JavaScript parsen und ausführen.
Das macht das auch so ein bisschen, dadurch, dass du
jetzt streng typisiertes TypeScript
hast und es als Snapshot
speicherst, macht es aus
JavaScript so eine
eigentlich halb kompilierte Sprache,
weil du nicht wirklich das Skript mehr evaluierst.
Das stimmt, ja, ja.
Wir sind also, was ich vor
einigen Folgen gesagt hatte, dass wir mit
JavaScript eigentlich nicht mehr so weit
weg sind, also mit TypeScript, eigentlich
nicht mehr so weit weg sind von sowas wie Java.
Das ist jetzt noch näher.
Es ist erstaunlich echt
ein guter
Punkt. Also dieses
ich importiere mir überall
URLs,
das war erst so ein bisschen off-putting für
mich, aber du kannst dir auch
dafür, viele Sachen, die
gehostet werden oder die veröffentlicht werden,
da zeigst du nicht unbedingt
auf irgendeine
URL von dem GitHub von irgendwem,
sondern du kannst es auch so veröffentlichen, dass du
deine Sachen unter
dino.land slash x
slash meine Library-Ad-Version
oder sowas kannst du auch angeben. Und du musst
es auch nicht in jeder einzelnen Datei schreiben.
Es gibt auch irgendwie so Import-Files, wo du
das zusammenfassen kannst. Es geht
irgendwie. Aber zumindest ist Dino
irgendwie JavaScript
außerhalb des Browsers
mal komplett neu gedacht.
Das ist eine super spannende Geschichte.
Mal Dinge mal wieder anders anzugehen
und mal drüber nachzudenken, was man so
ändern könnte. Und wir hatten diesen gesamten Blog
überhaupt nicht in unseren Shownotes drin, aber mir fiel ein,
dass ich mich seit der letzten Folge
damit auseinandergesetzt habe.
Die Programmiersprachen, über die wir
eigentlich reden wollten,
waren Ballerina und Kevin.
Aber ganz kurz, bevor wir dazu gehen,
kommen wir gleich zu. Wenn du gerade schon
bei Node warst, es gab noch einen witzigen NPM-Fuckup.
Ja, erzähl.
Beziehungsweise war es gar nicht so sehr ein NPM-Fuckup.
mehr ein Cloudflare-Fuck-up, wenn ich das
Postmodo richtig gelesen habe.
Gibt es ja auch einige mittlerweile.
Ja, passiert. Das Schöne an der
NPM-Welt ist ja, dass so ein
JavaScript-Projekt gerade während du es
baust, kaum
Request ins Internet abschickt.
Nee, gar nicht.
Bei Dino ist es nicht anders. Es hängt ja
nur deine ganze Build-Pipeline daran, dass du hier
10.000 Ressourcen
abfragen musst. Und das immer und immer
und immer wieder. Und das Witzige war, dass
Cloudflare ein paar Dinge umkonfiguriert hatte.
Cloudflare, gerade in dem Kontext auch mit
vor NPM
Servern
und da Rate Limiting
aus Versehen aktiviert hat.
Und bei vielen, vielen, vielen, vielen
Leuten ihre Build nicht mehr ging,
weil ihre Build Pipeline
drauf, also
nicht gerate limitet sein darf, weil die da
zigtausend Requests abschickt.
War ein bisschen spaßig.
Das Git habe ich schon mal verlinkt. Es ist halt
auch eine, ich will nicht sagen eine traurige
Realität. Es ist halt blöd, dass das
so gewachsen ist und das wird auch nur
exponentiell so weiter wachsen können.
Natürlich nicht. Aber da ist es mit
am schlimmsten. Ich frage mich
sowieso bei vielen Sachen. Also wenn ich jetzt heutzutage eine Sprache
verwende, die einen Paketmanager
hat. Also alles außer Go
quasi. Nein, Quatsch.
Keine Angst, der Go-Rant
geht nachher noch weiter. Ja, genau.
Wir hatten ja auch
mal gesagt, wir machen das nicht mehr.
Anyway.
Also wenn du heutzutage eine Sprache verwendest,
wie Swift,
wie Rust, wie
Python, wie Ruby, wie
Node oder JavaScript,
wo du einen Paketmanager hast, wo du in deiner
CI den Paketmanager
nimmst, um irgendwelche Sachen zu installieren.
Immer und immer und immer
wieder. Machst du ja ganz schön
viel dafür, dass du eigentlich, weiß ich nicht,
nur deinen Paket zum Test baust.
Jedes Mal, wenn du einen Commit gemacht hast oder so.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob es jede Firma oder jeder
Privatnutzer oder ich weiß nicht, wie es Travis
macht, ob die das wirklich
cachen.
Es gibt garantiert
sehr viele
CIs, die wirklich jedes Mal
zu NPM oder zu Crates.io
gehen.
Und wir sind schon
intern da auf Probleme
gestoßen. Wir haben bei uns Artifactory
laufen. Und Artifactory
kannst du halt auch einfach als
NPM-Cache verwenden. Das heißt, du sagst,
gibt es irgendwie in deiner NPM RC
als Registry nicht NPM,
sondern Artifactory an.
Und Artifactory sagt dann,
wenn du das fragst,
ob du mal hier Express installieren kannst,
sagst du, Express kenne ich nicht,
gehe ich mal kurz zu NPM,
hole ich mir das,
dann kannst du es dir von Artifactory installieren.
Und dadurch bleibt der Traffic
einigermaßen intern bei uns.
Es wird alles einmal geholt
und danach wird es intern.
Es bricht bei uns teilweise trotzdem zusammen.
Wir haben irgendwie Projekte,
so ein internes Test-Framework,
was wirklich sehr viele Dependencies hat,
was du, wenn du es in einen Test ausführst,
musst du dir dieses Test-Framework installieren
und dann den gesamten
Tree an Dependencies von dem
Ding installieren und das macht ziemlich viel
Traffic intern, da müssen wir gerade ein bisschen schauen,
dass du es vielleicht gebundelt installierst. Das sind Sachen, die dir
fallen dir auf, wenn du es auf deine eigene
Infrastruktur wirfst. Aber es gibt auch
tonnenweise Firmen da draußen, die den
ganzen Tag NPM-Dossen ohne...
Also ich finde es ja erstaunlich, dass
das Ding noch lebt. Also dass es vor allem
in der Größe weiter...
Da habe ich einen heilen Respekt vor.
Das geht mir nur Operation Fun.
Also gerade, ich meine, wenn du das Tool baust,
als NPM,
die Firma dahinter, die das Ding finanziert
und baut, baust du gleichzeitig
einen gigantischen Webservice
und ein Tool, das dafür gedacht ist, dich selber
die ganze Zeit weltweit zu dossen.
Genau.
Und das sehr effizient.
Und durch sowas wie CI kannst du
auch Downloadzahlen überhaupt nicht mehr vertrauen.
Also deswegen sind sie bei NPM,
wenn ich mir bei NPM bei einer Dependency
überlege, ob ich das nehme,
jetzt schaue ich mir die erste
Ableitung der Downloads der letzten Woche
an, so. Einfach, ob die hoch oder
runter geht. Aber sonst...
Hier mein einziges NPM-Package,
dvb.js. Oh, nur
neun Weekly Downloads? Ach, das ist ja...
Früher war das mal mehr, aber das war schon immer so eine Zahl,
die lächerlich hoch war. Wie viele Leute laden denn
bitte ein Package runter, mit dem du in Dresden
querying kannst, was auf den V-Date angeht?
Das ist einer, bei dem neunmal die Woche DCI läuft.
Ein Dependent. Und das ist auch ein Projekt von mir.
Scheiße, okay, ich habe zwei Packages.
Aber hat es nicht der Andreas mal irgendwie komplett aufgeräumt
und jetzt ist es irgendwie
wieder relevant oder so?
Ja, relevant ist halt trotzdem
brauchen das die wenigsten.
Das nutzen irgendwie drei private Alexa-Skills
von irgendwelchen Leuten,
die sich da Dinge basteln.
Stimmt, da war was.
Und das war es.
Wer braucht denn bitte ein Package dafür?
Das nutzt niemand.
Du könntest ja ein anderes Business drauf ausbauen.
Nee, aber das ging mir nicht darum.
Die Download-Zahlen sind halt schon immer Bullshit gewesen
an der Stelle. Früher war das mal in den
tiefen Hundertern. Und das ist einfach
völlig absurd. Das war einfach
Quatsch. Das sind Dinge gewesen, die waren nicht mal
darauf gedacht,
Projekte, die darauf aufbauen, immer wieder zu
bauen, sondern das waren einfach Dinge, die haben einfach
NPM gecrawlt, die ganze Zeit alles runtergeladen, was ging.
Deswegen habe ich mir, ich sage jetzt nicht,
wie es konkret heißt, aber deswegen habe ich
ein Crate auf Crate.io
veröffentlicht, das heißt Baseline irgendwas.
Das hast du mal erzählt. Wo ich gerade geschrieben habe,
weh, wenn das einer wirklich verwendet.
Ich möchte nur sehen, wie häufig hier alles
runtergeladen wird.
Das ist so quasi der Canary.
Witzige Idee.
Wir haben ja auch einmal
die Programmiersprache der Woche, als ob wir nicht schon genügend
über Programmiersprachen geredet hatten.
Heute ist mal wieder eine Programmiersprachen-lastige Folge, das stimmt.
Wir haben ja auch keine Gäste,
deswegen müssen wir auf unsere Standardthemen ausweichen.
Ich hatte hier zwischendurch
Unabhängig voneinander hier
zwei Sprachen rausgesucht. Genau, ich habe gefunden,
die Programmiersprache, und wir haben gerade schon ein bisschen versucht,
sie zu lesen, aber es geht irgendwie nicht.
Die Sprache heißt Kevin.
Low-Level-Performance-First Data-Oriented
Systems Language. Ich muss sagen,
ich stecke syntaktisch, ich verstehe
das nicht. Also da sind wirklich ein paar Konstrukte dabei,
also sowas wie Import, wir haben ja gerade
das Hello World vor der Nase, Import Console
from Console, das geht noch. Es ist ja auch eine
C-like Sprache, das ist jetzt nicht was komplett absurdes,
aber es ist syntaktisch. Es hat
Symbole, das haben sie wahrscheinlich von Ruby
geklaut.
Es hat auch so Unarten,
das sehe ich gerade in dem Hello World, dass die oben
das FN Symbol
Main deklarieren.
Achso, ist das
Returned, das Symbol, okay?
Und dann haben wir
auf der letzten Zeile Export Main stehen.
Schreiben es nicht davor.
Warum?
Oder überhaupt, warum musst du
bei einem Hello World deinen
Main exportieren?
Es sind auch ein paar interessante Namen hier.
Wenn du mal in die Basic Types reingehst, sind
Dinge wie Jagged Arrays gelistet.
Jagged Arrays are arrays of arrays
and are not stored in continuous memory.
These are slower and have less memory efficiency
than a multidimensional array.
Ich meine, okay, aber der Name
Jagged Array ist auch
eine nette Neuschöpfung davon.
Das klingt auch wie eine Band.
Das ist ein guter Name.
Also zumindest Kevin, schaut es euch an.
Wir können die Syntax ehrlich gesagt so
ohne Kontext nicht verstehen, weil da sind
Symbol- und Operatorkombinationen
drin, die ich so nicht erwartet hätte.
Ich verstehe, das ist ja nur
bedingt.
Was ich schön finde ist,
Das Function-Keyword ist FN.
Okay.
Das freut sich ein.
Und du kannst auch, die Typen
stehen hinten und du hast
das Mute-Keyword auf Argumenten.
Das heißt, das ist auch schon mal schön.
Ich hatte neulich mal
überlegt, ob das in TypeScript gehen würde,
dass du so ein Read-Only als
Argumenten-Modifikator annimmst,
damit du nicht die, weil das in JavaScript
manchmal passiert, dass wenn du ein Objekt reinkriegst,
dass du da drin rumschreibst und dann hast du natürlich
nur eine Referenz auf das Objekt gehabt und hast
da drin was verändert. Aber bei
TypeScript gibt es diese geilen
Map-Types.
Das heißt, du kannst irgendwie einen Typen
von einem anderen Interface erzeugen,
wo du bestimmte
Sachen erinnerst. Zum Beispiel
Read-Only-T, wo du
ein Interface reinkriegst und da sind aber dann
alle Properties Read-Only, die kannst du dann nicht mehr anfassen.
Du könntest also theoretisch in TypeScript
ein Objekt reinkriegen und das aber als
Read-Only-Objekt
annehmen und dann darfst du nicht mehr darauf schreiben,
aus Versehen. Spannend.
Weißt du, worauf Kevin läuft?
Ich habe ihn nicht ganz verstanden.
Ich habe einen Kollegen, der heißt
Kevin.
Hier steht nirgendwo was von wegen
auf was. Nicht Plattform, sondern
Es ist eine Systems-Sprache.
Das könnt ihr mir vorstellen,
dass es kompiliert.
Ich fehlen auch einfach Informationen.
Achso, die Seite ist einfach ein bisschen unübersichtlich.
Wenn ich auf Home gehe, ist das Menü weg.
Dann gehe ich auf Docs.
Da gibt es Learn und da taucht
plötzlich ein ganz anderes Menü auf.
und dann siehst du plötzlich
und das ist allerdings,
da ist dann das Highlighting manchmal.
Also schaut euch mal Kevin an. Kevin ist interessant.
Ich verstehe es nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob es überhaupt
lebt oder tot ist. Das geht halt über nicht.
Also gerade eben hätte ich noch gesagt, da ist
überhaupt nichts auf der Website. Dann hat sich plötzlich
dieses Untermenü geöffnet, was vorher nicht da war.
Es gibt aber Nullables.
Anyway. Und es gibt
Fail und Eject Keywords.
Was ist denn deine Sprache?
Ich bin letztens auf Hackern News über Ballerina gestolpert,
was ich interessant fand, weil ich vorher noch nie was davon gehört habe,
aber das Projekt erstaunlich groß ausschaut und die Kommentare auch alle sehr positiv waren.
Aber du musst mal in die Examples gehen.
Es ist erstaunlich viel da.
Das ist eine Sprache, die ist JVM-basiert,
hat also Kompatibilität oder Interop mit allem, was auf der JVM so läuft,
auch wenn der Java-Interop ein bisschen umständlich ausschaut, syntaktisch.
Also sie muss die Dinge erst irgendwie noch reinmappen
in Native Ballerina-Types
und damit dann Dinge,
alles nochmal deklarieren, was du auf den Java-Ding
machen möchtest. Wo finde ich denn hier die Examples?
Einfach auf den fetten Ballerina-by-Example-Button
klicken auf der Startseite.
Da gibt es drei Buttons. Ah, Ballerina-by-Example.
Genau, und das ist erstaunlich viel Kram.
Hello World Parallel.
Die Sprache hat halt
eingebaut, das Konzept von irgendwie
Services, von
Concurrency und
so wie ich das verstanden habe,
kommunizieren diverse Module in dieser Sprache
auch alle über, also wenn du möchtest,
über HTTP.
Was ich interessant finde, wenn ich das
korrekt so verstanden habe. Und die Standardbibliothek
ist erstaunlich groß und beinhaltet irgendwie
alles, was du haben möchtest, wenn du
irgendwelche Services schreiben
möchtest. Ob das jetzt hier ein Prometheus-Client
ist oder ob das hier einfach nur
irgendwie Web-Server-Fu ist, ob das
keine Ahnung, hier alles drin ist.
Ich finde diese Beispiel-
wo du dich im ersten Moment wundernst,
warum sind da 35 Leerzeilen dazwischen?
Ich finde das ziemlich cool,
weil wenn du drüber hoferst, dann wird an der Seite
dieser Textblock gehighlighted, der dir erklärt, was in dieser
Zeile passiert. Was ein bisschen schwach ist, wenn du da
in dem Editor Dinge markierst,
dass er die Beispiele und die Zeilnummern mitmarkiert
und du somit nicht Dinge rauskopieren kannst.
Das fand ich ein bisschen lahm beim Versuch,
das auszuprobieren.
Aber auf jeden Fall
erstaunlich komplett, das fand ich beeindruckend.
Und kann man sich auf jeden Fall mal
anschauen. Ich finde es gar nicht verkehrt,
auf der JVM laufen, weil dann weiß man, dass man ein Battle-Proven
Environment auf jeden Fall hat. Ich weiß gar nicht,
ich will dir jetzt nichts unterstellen, aber kriegt man nicht, wenn man
JVM, auf der
JVM läuft, einfach sehr viel geschenkt, wenn man einfach
ein bisschen Rapper dafür schreibt, dann hast du quasi
unten drunter ein bisschen eine Java-Library laufen
oder sowas. Sicherlich kann es sein.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel hiervon implementiert ist
auf Java-Basis, kann natürlich auf jeden Fall mitkommen
und das hat dir das Leben einfach gemacht.
Es ist auf jeden Fall eine wesentlich umfangreichere Seite
als die von Kevin. Tut mir leid,
Kevin, aber da hast du einfach,
wer nennt auch seine Sprache Kevin?
Ich hatte mal
meine eigene Sprache angefangen.
Ich versuche gerade mich zu erinnern, wie die hieß.
Schwalbe.
Nee, Schwalbe zählt nicht.
Schwalbe war ein schlechter Witz.
Fakt, es war irgendein Wortwitz mit meinem eigenen Namen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es eine Kylian-Sprache gibt.
Kylian-Skript, aber dann irgendwie einfach nur Kripp draus geworden?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Irgendwas in der Richtung war es.
Es war auch mehr so ein syntaktisches
Rumgespiele mit einem Interpreter und das Ganze war
so ein Basic-Äquivalent, weil ich keine Ahnung hatte.
Das ist auch eine Weile her.
Also ich muss nicht weit scrollen,
wenn ich nach Kilian Programming Language
suche, bis ich dein
GitHub finde. Cool.
Freut mich.
Ja, aber Ballerina fand ich, wie gesagt,
erstaunlich komplett. Vor allem dafür,
ich will nicht sagen, dass es hier irgendwas
heißt, wenn ich Dinge nicht kenne,
aber ich hatte davon noch nie was gehört.
Und das kam so ein Gefühl aus dem Nichts und das fand ich krass.
Nicht schlecht. Es ist wirklich eine gut dokumentierte Sprache.
Das muss ich dazu sagen.
Da kann sich Kevin noch einige abschneiden.
Wenn wir apropos noch bei Sprachen, das letzte Thema, was ich gerade in unserer Themenliste hier zu Sprachen finde,
ist mal wieder ein Go-Rant, der heute durchs Internet ging.
I want off Mr. Go-Lang's Wild Ride.
I want off Mr. Go-Lang's Wild Ride, ja genau.
Das ist von dem, ich weiß gerade gar nicht, wie er heißt,
Na, Faster Than Lime.
Was macht denn der Typ?
Faster Than Lime?
Ich würde vielleicht einen Schnitt reinmachen.
Amos. Ach, der Typ.
Was macht Amos?
Der postet auch Sachen,
den habe ich in meinem Twitter-Feed auch.
Der postet auch über Strings
und Rust oder sowas.
Und
über sehr viel C und C++, also der
steckt schon. Ach, genau.
Also, der Post heißt
I want off Mr. Golang's Wild Ride. Das ist von
diesem Amos. Das ist unter anderem der Typ,
der H.I.O. gebaut hat.
Diese Indie-Gaming-Plattform.
Und
bekannter Mensch in generell
der Go- und Rust-Welt und
andere. Der hat einen ziemlich coolen Blog.
Auf jeden Fall mal wieder. Der Blog ist vor allem
so ein Blog, den ich auch gerne hätte, der voll mit
Code-Beispielen und Grafiken ist.
Das ist herrlich. Und der hat ziemlich viel
in letzter Zeit, was heißt in letzter Zeit,
in den letzten Jahren mit Go gemacht und
hat hier diesen schönen Post geschrieben.
Erster Satz, my honeymoon with
the Go-Language is extremely over.
und eigentlich zerpflückt
er zwei Sachen, die ihn am Go
sehr stören.
Zum einen, dass die ganzen
File-APIs
keine Ahnung haben, dass es verschiedene
Plattformen gibt. Die gehen einfach von Unix
als dem Default aus und
funktionieren einfach nicht auf Windows.
Ja gut, also
das ist, ich meine, das kann man
sehen so, ja okay, die Plattform interessiert
mich nicht, auf der anderen Seite ist das einfach
Das sollte aber von der Sprache, von der
Library irgendwie wegabstroniert werden.
Oder das als Handwerkszeug in die Hand gegeben.
Auch wenn es ihm leid tut, vergleicht er das hier mit Rust und
wie Rust es halt auf Typebene schon sicherstellt,
dass du Dinge nicht, dem nicht machst
oder einfach, dass Dinge nicht funktionieren können.
Zum Beispiel diese, hier hast du
die Go-APIs geben dir die Möglichkeit,
die Metadaten
von einer Datei abzugreifen im Sinne von
die Rechte, die
halt gesetzt sind. Im Unix-Kontext
in Form von diesen
die Rechte,
die in einer Datei gesetzt sind. Im Unix-Kontext
wie man sie halt kennt hier.
Raid Riot Execute. Genau, genau.
Für User World Group.
Und diese API hast du halt
auf Windows und dann gibt es diese Daten.
Dieses Konzept existiert halt gar nicht.
Windows kannst du es viel komplexer machen.
Deswegen rät das Ding, rät Go einfach
und schmeißt dir irgendwelche Daten hin,
die einfach nicht existieren.
Das ist halt einfach Bullshit. Das ist Quatsch.
Und mal abgesehen davon,
dass du halt hier dem Windows-Beispiel
rumgehst und zum Beispiel hier mit
bis sie den UTF-8 fuhr durch die
Gegend kommt,
und dann wieder den Rust-Vergleich macht, er kommt halt
letztendlich auf den kritischen Punkt,
dass Go halt versucht,
simpel zu sein,
aber auch
zwanghaft simpel zu sein bei Dingen,
die einfach nicht simpel sind.
Und dass Go's Simplicity
halt wirklich sich selbst im Weg steht,
die Komplexität von Themen
einfach versteckt, die existiert
dann gar nicht für den Go-Entwickler
und dann bist du halt einfach angeschmiert
wenn du da rein rennst, weil es gibt keine Möglichkeit, das sauber zu umgehen.
Ja, Go war einfach auch
nicht dafür gedacht, dass du es auf Windows baust.
Aber es läuft da
und es gibt ja halt die ganzen API.
Geht es ja hauptsächlich darum, wie Go auf Windows?
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Es geht ihm später auch um
monotone Zeitrechnungen. Das ist ein echt interessanter
Post. Es steht oben da, 33 Minuten
Lesezeit. Go hat sehr viele
Trade-offs gemacht, um eine simple Sprache zu bauen.
Sie haben erfolgreich eine sehr simple
Sprache gebaut und
damit haben sie aber einfach den
bestimmte Use Cases verbaut.
Ja, aber so verbaut, dass du sie halt
nicht ordentlich abbilden kannst.
Und das ist hier auch am Ende
die Parting Words, die er hier geschrieben hat.
Over and over, go is a victim of its own mantra.
Simplicity. It constantly takes
power away from its users, reserving it for itself.
It constantly lies
about how complicated real-world systems are.
Und es optimiert für die 90%
und ignoriert einfach Korrektheit.
Und da hat er absolut recht.
Ich kann den Post wirklich wärmstens empfehlen.
Es sind ein paar Beispiele.
ist die Windows-Kompatibilität am Anfang, es ist
die monotone System-Site,
die abgefragt werden kann,
bei der Go einfach lügt
und diverse andere Sachen.
Ich hab's mal in meinem Pocket aufgedacht. Kann ich, kann ich
wärmstens empfehlen. Er zieht oftmals
den Vergleich zu Rust. Wie gesagt, entschuldigt
sich dafür, weil er das eigentlich gar nicht machen möchte,
weil sonst klingt es halt wirklich wie so ein Post von wegen
hier ist ein Rust-Station, der meint, Go ist scheiße, aber
er ist halt... Das kommt einem halt
meistens bloß so vor, wenn die Leute sich Rust angucken.
Das sind wirklich... Diese Person hat halt auch
Ahnung, der hat jahrelang Go geschrieben und
es stören ihn echt Dinge,
die Go einfach nicht korrekt
macht. Und das finde ich einen sehr
validen Kritikpunkt
hier. Das ist ein Rant, der ganze Post,
aber ein sehr gut begründeter Rant.
Ist echt
richtig gut. Hast du den
Fuchsia,
die Fuchsia-Seite, die ich verlinkt habe,
dir angeschaut? Pass auf.
Es gibt, also Fuchsia ist der Begriff? Oder Fuchsia?
Ja. Kannst du mir sagen, was Fuchsia ist?
Ja, ich hatte das nicht als
Sprache im Kopf, sondern eher als neue Plattform
Google. Das ist ein neues Betriebssystem.
Nicht nur ein Kernel,
sondern wirklich ein Betriebssystem. Ich dachte auch erst,
es ist nur ein Kernel, mit dem sie vielleicht irgendwann
Lux ersetzen wollen, aber es ist wirklich ein Betriebssystem
insgesamt. Der Kernel heißt
Zirkon.
Und die wird,
die ist mir in letzter Zeit auch häufiger halt im Begriff
gewesen, sorry, ich hab ihn halt
Rustation, weil
angeblich 50% von
Fuchs ja in Rust geschrieben sind.
Oder mehr als 50%, hat zumindest der Florian
noch behauptet. Ich hab das mal nachgeguckt.
Ich habe tatsächlich auch als Vorbereitung, weil ich
noch einen Talk darüber gehalten hatte bei mir auf Arbeit,
da hatte ich es nochmal nachgeguckt, ich habe mir wirklich den
Fuchsia-Code ausgecheckt und
Log draufgeschmissen und dann hat es halt
gesagt, 50% Rust, 50% C++.
Der
Kernel ist in C geschrieben und was aber allerdings
bei Google noch der Fall ist,
okay, die machen jetzt hier ein Betriebssystem
in C++ und Rust, aber die haben
doch noch selber noch zwei andere Sprachen, nämlich
Go und Dart. Und
das Ding hier ist, diese Seite hier ist auf
Hacker News neulich mal an mir vorbeigescrollt
Der Fuchsia Programming Language
Guide. Ne, Quatsch.
Die Fuchsia Programming Language Policy.
Da wird irgendwie aufgezählt,
das ist einfach eine sehr schöne Zusammenfassung
von den Programmiersprachen,
die man im Fuchsia-Umfeld verwenden kann.
Und Pros und Cons und eine Empfehlung
dazu. Da steht drin C.
C++.
Also Kudos an Google, dass die
beiden Sprachen nicht zusammenfassen.
Dart, Rust, Go und Python.
Python auch eine Liste.
Python auch. Und dann gibt es halt so Beschreibungen
ich bin mal kurz,
also Analysis C++,
Pro, many of our current
end developers use C++ extensively,
Pro, the Fuchsia platform
Source 3 uses C++
extensively, Pro,
C++ is a widely used language,
the language has properties
that are well understood, und so weiter und so fort,
Con, support
for asynchronous programming is
weak,
done by Dart,
Pro, the current
end-user developers already
use the language. The majority of Fuchsia
user interfaces are built
with Flutter, which uses Start.
Pro,
people using the language
are highly productive.
Das ist ein geiles Pro.
Finde ich ein bisschen subjektiv.
Ja, also für user interfaces
stimmt es tatsächlich.
Bei Rust ist es
the Fuchsia platform
SourceTree has had a positive
Implementation Experience using Rust.
Pro, ich skippe auch welche,
Pro, asynchronous programming
can be written using straight-line
code. Das ist einfach, wir haben auch
auf dem Rust-Fest einen Vortrag drüber gehalten,
Async-Await in Rust gibt ja einfach
geile Performance-Garantien gegenüber
asynchronem Code in C++
zum Beispiel. Und Con,
Rust is not a widely
used language. The properties of the language
are not well understood, having
selected an unusual
language designed
EG BorrowChecker and having
existed only for
a relatively short period of time.
Das klingt äußerst subjektiv.
Das ist eher so,
der Con ist eher,
es ist noch nicht komplett abgehauen.
Es ist noch zu obskur.
Nee, es klingt so,
ich meine, die wissen ja, was es ausgehen.
Oder wir kennen uns noch nicht super gut damit aus.
Hier steht ja auch,
none of our current and developers use Rust.
Ja, das ist so die Sache.
Die benutzen es für das Betriebssystem,
Aber zum Beispiel würden sie, glaube ich,
keine Apps empfehlen, mit Rust zu schreiben.
So, jetzt kommt hier
Go Analysis.
Go is a widely used language within Google.
Pro, Pro, Pro, Pro.
Con, the language is garbage collected.
Con, the language has substantial
runtime environment.
Ach, hier der Schlitzepunkt.
The Fusher Platform Source Tree has had negative
implementation experiences using Go.
Genau, und das Schöne ist, bei jeder Sprache steht auch noch
eine Decision unten drunter.
Also bei C++ steht
decision. C++ is supported for
end development. C++
is supported for usage throughout
the Fuchsia
Platform Source Tree. For Rust,
steht da, Rust is not supported for
end user development,
for end developers. Also für die Leute, die
auf Fuchsia entwickeln.
Rust is
approved for use throughout
the Fuchsia Platform Source
Tree with the following exceptions.
Kernel, im Kernel wollen sie halt nur C verwenden.
Okay.
Und jetzt bei Go.
Go is not approved with the following
exceptions, nämlich dem NetStack,
den zu migrieren wäre, nämlich
den haben sie einmal in Go geschrieben und den zu migrieren wäre
would require a significant
investment.
Das ist aber fair, wenn die halt ein abgeschlossenes
Modul haben, dass du ein bisschen so Microservices
denken hier. Das ist ja okay, wenn die das
da halten.
All other uses of Go in the
Fuchsia Platform Source Tree for
production software on the target
Device must be migrated to an approved
language.
Finde ich schon, dass gerade die Firma die Go entwickelt hat,
oder wo Go herrscht,
Google ist kacke.
Google does not approve of Go.
Ja, aber ich meine,
das ist auch wirklich,
wir machen jetzt schon wieder ein bisschen Shit-Talking draus,
aber hier geht es um Betriebssystementwicklung.
Es geht nicht darum, dass du Web-Services
baust, da kannst du
auf einem Web-Service kannst du Ramm fressen,
meinetwegen.
Und dafür ist auch
entwickelt worden, aber nicht für
ein Betriebssystem.
Die eine Sache
ist, dass du halt auf einem Rechenzentrum
von Google läufst. Die andere ist, dass du
irgendwie bei einem auf der Armbanduhr
oder in der Hosentasche auf dem
Telefon läufst. Da solltest du möglichst effizient
sein.
Hier rät
Google von Go explizit ab.
Das fand ich eigentlich eine ziemlich
witzige Sache. Ansonsten, die Details auf dieser Seite
finde ich eigentlich ziemlich gut geschrieben.
Schmeißen es mal in die Shownotes.
Es ist auch kein Blogpost oder sowas.
Es ist einfach ein internes Dokument.
Eher das ist zu finden unter,
das ist im Source-Tree,
unter Docs Project Policy Programming Language Guide MD.
Es ist ja auch keine offizielle Google-Aussage hier.
Es ist das Fusia-Projekt,
was für sich eine Policy dahin schreibt.
Stimmt, das ist das Fusia-Projekt.
Das ist nicht Google.
Das stimmt.
Also das ist auch nichts,
was die hier offiziell so proklamiert haben.
Es hat bloß auf irgendeinem Weg
seinen Weg auf
Hackernews gefunden.
Aber interessant auf jeden Fall.
Das ist zumindest eine schöne Analyse für Programmierensprachen,
die man auch in seiner Firma anwenden könnte,
um zu sagen, guck mal hier,
so denkt Google Entwickler
und ja, es macht keinen Sinn
oder es ist momentan noch nicht empfehlenswert,
gewisse Sachen in dieser oder jeder Sprache zu machen,
aus diesen Gründen.
Da bin ich auch realistisch.
Da kann man abwägen.
Ist ja legitim. Nicht jede Sprache hat das Ziel,
überall angewendet werden zu wollen.
Nee, muss ja auch nicht. Es gibt auch Sachen, die du mit Rust nie machen wirst.
Es gibt Sachen, die wirst du mit Dart nie machen.
Und witzigerweise sieht man diese Sachen auch hier genau.
Also ich denke nicht, dass Rust zu einer signifikanten User-Interface
oder User-Application-Programmiersprache werden wird.
Zumindest nicht für, und dieser Begriff ist mir neu, aber er passt eigentlich,
End-Developers.
Man könnte es eher fast nennen, Front-End-Developers.
Nicht ganz, aber es geht schon darum,
das sind die, die wirklich User-Facing-Code schreiben.
Ja, das ist eigentlich witzig,
vor dem End-User noch den End-Developer zu haben.
Ja, wirklich für das komische End-Developer.
Ja, ist ja verständlich, wenn sie eine Plattform schreiben,
eine Plattform, auf der andere Leute auch Tools entwickeln,
beziehungsweise nicht auf der Leute Tools entwickeln,
sondern für die Leute Tools entwickeln,
oder Dinge entwickeln, die dann halt darauf laufen.
Dann hast du halt noch eine Ebene weiter.
Genau.
Ja, ich meine, die hast du immer, aber...
der Gedanke ist auf jeden Fall valide.
Sagen wir es so. Auf jeden Fall.
Cool.
Ja, das war, glaube ich, so grob alles aus unseren
Topics, die wir heute haben. Da hat sich echt
einiges aufgestaut gehabt. Ja, meine Fassern.
Wollen wir zu unseren Pics übergeben? Du hast ja
HTTP 203 schon vorgegriffen gehabt.
Genau, also schaut euch diesen Podcast
beziehungsweise diesen YouTube-Channel an. Ich habe das
jetzt in letzter Zeit immer mal gemacht. Das ist
eine schöne Runde. Wie googelt man danach?
Auf YouTube nach
HTTP 203 suchen.
Das sind zwei Typen,
die siehst du auch manchmal auf Google.io, wie sie
Vorträge halten, durchaus
sehr gut informiert
und es sind auch im Gegensatz zu unserem
Podcast, also die Nische ist so ein bisschen ähnlich, es ist
auch vom Konzept her ein bisschen
ähnlich, weil es sich so einfach zwei Kumpels
gegenüber sitzen und sich gegenseitig was erzählen,
aber sie sind, was die Themen an geht,
sehr gut vorbereitet und die Folgen sind immer bloß so 20 Minuten
lang, also es geht zum Beispiel,
es geht 20 Minuten oder 15
Minuten mal eben nur über
Modulsysteme
weblastig. Also sie sind häufig
Web- oder JavaScript-Themen. Aber die publishen nur
auf YouTube? Sehe ich das richtig? Die publishen
das auf YouTube und haben einen Podcast.
Ach, die haben doch einen Podcast.
Das sind, glaube ich, zwei separate Sachen.
Ich habe mir letztens mal ein spannendes Tool gedehnt.
Ich wollte sowas und habe das ein bisschen
ungegüblich gefunden. Ich habe mir das aufgesetzt.
Das läuft jetzt auch bei mir auf dem Server mit. Das heißt
PodSync. Dem gebe ich
YouTube
Channels.
Zwei YouTube-Channels. Und der lädt
konvertiert die via FNPack einfach zu einem Audio-Dateil,
legt noch eine XML daneben
und publischt die einfach für mich privat als Podcast,
sodass ich zwei spezifische YouTube-Channel
einfach als Podcast in meinem Podcast-Client hören kann
und die automatisch bei mir auftauchen,
weil die jetzt für mich private Podcasts sind.
Das finde ich sehr, sehr angenehm.
Ich habe mich gerade gewundert,
was diese Seite mir sagen will,
weil sie sehr viel Werbung führt,
die EarPods macht,
aber ich habe mich vertippt,
ich bin nicht auf Podsync,
sondern auf Podsnyc.
Das ist POTS NYC.
Das hat überhaupt nichts damit zu tun.
Cool.
Ja, finde ich ein witziges Tool.
Also das ist, ich
mache relativ viel mit Pocket,
weil Pocket mir auch einfach Sachen vorliest.
Dann schmeiße ich immer mal, wenn ich einen Blog poste,
wie den gerade eben, ein bisschen ungünstig mit Code,
aber schmeiße ich in meine Pocket rein.
Das ist so eine Art Leseliste für mich.
Die kann ich auf dem iPad lesen oder auf dem Telefon lesen
oder auf dem Telefon auf Lieses mir vorklicken.
Da habe ich auch mal so ein Ding benutzt,
wo du halt Artikel reinspeichern konntest
dass es einen privaten Podcast-Feed auch daraus generiert hat.
Genau, und das Pocket macht das eigentlich ziemlich nah.
Also wenn ich da auf Play drücke und der mit dem Ding zu Ende ist,
liest das nächste Ding.
Ja, die Podding macht das explizit nur für YouTube-Videos,
wo du halt nichts generieren musst,
sondern bloß quasi die Audio-Zug.
Aber Podding klingt so ein bisschen,
als könnte man das auch in zwei Stunden selber bauen,
weil mit YouTube-DL klickst du das ziemlich gut.
Wahrscheinlich, das ist auch quasi YouTube-DL zusammengesteckt mit FFM-Pack.
Brauchst du das eigentlich mal als FFM-Pack,
weil du kannst einfach mit YouTube-DL-X direkt das Audio rausziehen.
Genau, und der legt das Outlook noch,
dazu und legt den ordentlichen Podcast-Feed an.
Das ist ein Drei-Zeilen-Code.
Das macht es natürlich dann.
Das fertige Projekt ist ein GitHub-Projekt,
das legst du dir einfach irgendwo hin
und lässt es laufen und legst über eine Konfigur-Datei
und sagst, hier ist der Feed, bitte.
Und dann läuft das. Jetzt kann ich mir die, kurz gesagt,
Videos einfach als Podcast
anhören.
Die sind schön, aber ich
habe die auch lange in meiner Q-Dring, in meinem RSS-Feeder
habe ich die YouTube-Channel abonniert, aber
ich schaue die einfach nicht, weil ich schaue keine YouTube-Videos.
Ich habe da einfach keine Lust dazu,
YouTube-Videos anzuschauen. Na gut, das kann ich
auch ein bisschen nachvollziehen. Ich habe
mir neulich dieses kurz gesagt,
nochmal Tipp, kurz gesagt,
das heißt wirklich so, ist auf Englisch,
aber heißt es kurz gesagt. Es gibt beides, es gibt den Deutschen und den
Englischen. Die beiden habe ich halt drin, weil die unterschiedlichen Content haben.
Das heißt
kurz gesagt und dann als
Subtitel in a nutshell.
Wir haben
neulich ein Video über sich
Meta gemacht, wie lange sie brauchen, um so ein Video
zu produzieren. Und
einen Shop und ihr könnt uns auch unterstützen, die mir Zeugs kauft.
Ich bin jetzt der stolze Besitzer von zwei Postern
und zwei paar, kurz gesagt, Zocken.
Kurz gesagt, Zocken ist ja geil.
Muss ich dir nachher mal zeigen.
Ja, cool,
Podsync, also. Was wollte ich
erwähnen? Ich habe
wo habe ich denn das
hingeschrieben? Ich habe
das, was ich hier reingeschrieben habe, das ist schon eine Weile her,
aber es gibt ein Projekt, das heißt
YGlue, jetzt muss ich mal selber hingucken,
das ist,
wenn ich mir die Webseite angucke, sollte es wahrscheinlich
Igloo aussprechen.
Und das ist ein Superset
von YAML, was dir
darauf aufbauend eine Query-Language
erlaubt und so eine Art,
das wird evaluiert und erzeugt dann wieder
neues YAML.
Das ist also
so eine Art XSL für YAML.
Und ich habe mir gedacht,
why though?
Was ist der Name?
YGlue.
Also ich meine, YAML war mal
schön, bis man festgestellt hat, was man
Jamil alles machen kann und dann hat man irgendwie Angst
bekommen vor Jamil, ich zumindest.
Und man sollte, glaube ich, mit Jamil
eher aufhören. Deswegen ist mein eigentlicher Tipp
nicht YGlue. YGlue war bloß der
Anhaltspunkt dafür,
weil es mal auf
Hacker News stand.
Sinnvoller fast
ist JSONnet.
JSONnet
habe ich dahinter, glaube ich, verlinkt.
JSONnet.org. Und das ist quasi
dasselbe. Das ist ein Superset von JSON
mit so halbem
Skript anteilen und da
kannst du mit Templates
oder mit Primitiven
kannst du wirkliches JSON
erzeugen. Und warum zum Gaia
macht man das? Wir benutzen
es auf Arbeit gerade sehr intensiv,
darauf hat bei uns
jemand ein internes Projekt gebaut, wer weiß, ob wir sie
jetzt open sourcen. Wir benutzen
es intensiv, um damit zum Beispiel Grafana
Bots zu generieren.
Also du kannst Grafana entweder stundenlang
zusammenklickern
und dir dann JSON speichern und
JSON, was meterlang ist, weil es wirklich
jedes Feld beinhaltet,
kopieren und generieren. Oder du nimmst
sowas wie JSON.net und baust dir quasi
eine minimale, also du sollst damit keine Sachen
programmieren, du sollst damit wirklich nur Code erzeugen,
baust dir eine minimale
Metasprache
obendrauf, eine
Domain-Specific-Language obendrauf und generierst
dir damit deine
GraphQL, nein, deine
Grafana-Konfiguration.
Dafür ist es eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Also wir haben jetzt für unsere Services, die ja alle irgendwie nach Prometheus publishen oder von Prometheus gepolt werden, stecken wir, wenn wir irgendwelche neuen Counter oder sowas hinzufügen, modifizieren wir gleichzeitig noch so eine JSON-Datei und dann taucht für diesen Counter automatisch ein Feld im Grafana auf.
Interessanter Use Case.
Ja, das ist zumindest ein ziemlich krasses
Ding. Da
könnte man eigentlich mal, vielleicht
lade ich den Kollegen, der darüber
das gebaut hat, mal hierher ein.
Das wäre eigentlich mal ganz spannend.
Apropos YAML, ich habe letztens noch einen schönen Tweet gesehen,
den wollte ich dir eigentlich noch zeigen.
Hier hat einer in seinem YAML eine Property,
die heißt Countries. Und Countries ist
eine Liste von Länderidentifiern.
Also einfach Klammer auf und dann ein paar Länderidentifier
und die werden von YAML ja automatisch
zu Strings dann gemacht, weil er sie nicht explizit
gecoated hat, da ist NL, IT,
DK, NO.
Da ist bestimmt auch was dabei, was ein Keyword in YAML ist.
Ja, nämlich das ist ein NO und die Liste, die rauskommt,
ist nämlich der String NL, der String IT, der String
DK und false.
Dann ist es
YAML 1.1, weil bei YAML 1.2
haben sie es wieder deprecated.
Das ist ja das Fiese an YAML. Ich habe darauf basierend
ja auch eine relativ umfangreiche
Anwendung gemacht und bei
YAML hast du unterschiedliche, weil es ja
möglichst schön für die Menschen sein soll, hast du
unterschiedliche Keywords
für True und False, so wie bei CoffeeScript
auch. Bei CoffeeScript kannst du
sagen, True, False, On, Off,
Yes, No. Und bei
YAML hast du auch Yes und No.
Und das war schön,
bis sie sich gedacht haben, ist eigentlich nicht so schön.
Und dann haben sie aus der YAML
1.1-Spec, wo das drin vorkommt,
die YAML 1.2-Spec gemacht
und plötzlich evaluieren
No's wieder zu Strings.
Was auch scheiße ist.
Ich meine, es ist schön, aber es ist scheiße, dass sie wieder rausgenommen
haben, weil
bei meinem Tool, das ist ja von
Ruby, was es noch gemacht hat, zu Rust
importiert, was es dann nicht mehr gemacht hat. Ich prüfe
bei etwas, ob es true ist, indem ich
schaue, ob es true ist.
Nee, eigentlich nur,
ob es nicht der String
no ist.
Oder was?
Es ist false, wenn es nicht der String yes ist
oder wenn es ein Boolean ist.
Okay.
Also alles ist false.
Es sei denn, es steht explizit yes.
Der Falsi hier.
Das ist fürchterlich.
Jamel
macht's nicht.
Macht's einfach nicht.
Aber cool, du musst mir mal erklären, wie
Twitter funktioniert, ehrlich gesagt.
Es gibt irgendwie, in letzter Zeit gab es einige
Male so Tweets, so
Tweetketten, wo
jemand
einen anderen Tweet einfach mit
Kommentartweets retweetet hat.
Diese Quotes, ja.
Dieses quote me with so und so, if you
so und so. Ja, aber du siehst die ja nicht
als der ursprüngliche.
Und genau, ich sehe, dass das retweetet
wurde, aber wenn ich auf das ursprüngliche Ding
als jemand Außenstehender klicke, sehe ich
nicht alle diese. Die Quotes werden da nicht verlinkt,
das finde ich auch kacke. Vor allem siehst du es als
der Gequotete nicht, dass das
existiert. Doch, das siehst du.
Du siehst, wurde retweetet.
Das kriegst du zumindest mal als Notification.
Du kriegst es mal als Notification.
Aber es wird auch nicht,
Es wird, glaube ich, nicht wirklich auf die gleiche Art und Weise
bei Retweets gezählt.
Und
du kannst auch
dieser Kette nur runterfolgen.
Du kannst ja nicht hochfolgen.
Es gibt momentan so eine schöne Kette.
Da kannst du fünfmal reinklicken
und dann wieder rückwärts gehen.
Das ging los mit
Es geht heute um.
Warte mal, ich muss mal hier so ein paar Tweets folgen.
Es geht los mit
Hi, I'm a Senior Engineer.
You might know me from my greatest hits.
But why is it null?
There is a greater honor in deleting code
than writing code.
And the chart topping,
let's just walk over to them and ask.
Das Wort retweetet und verändert.
Natürlich.
Hi, I'm an Orchiculture expert in tech.
Hi, I'm a staff engineer.
Hi, I'm a developer advocate.
Hi, I'm a junior software engineer.
Das fand ich schön.
You might know me from my hits.
Sorry, I have a question.
Sorry if I have a silly question.
And sorry if I've asked you this before.
And my chart topping.
Sorry to bother you again.
Und noch irgendwie ein bekannter
Hi, I'm a VP of Engineering.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass der VP of Engineering ist.
Und so weiter und so fort.
Da habe ich auch noch eins dran gehängt.
Aber du kannst dieser Kette halt nur runterfolgen.
Das ist ja eine gute alte Zeit,
dass Twitter das Konzept von Retreats gar nicht kannte
und Leute einfach RT selber hingeschrieben haben.
Das war auch cool.
Weil mittlerweile hat ja, und das hatten wir auf diesem Podcast erwähnt,
mittlerweile hat Twitter
auch Bookmarks.
Aha.
Du kannst jetzt Tweets bookmarken.
Okay.
Und die Taxonomie davon hatte ich schon mal aufgezählt
und dann schon mal ich es zusammenkriege.
Also du kannst Sachen liken, retweeten
und bookmarken.
Und die haben drei unterschiedliche
Audienzen.
Liken ist für denjenigen, der es geschrieben hat,
damit du dem ein Thumbs up gibst.
Und für deine Follower.
Ah ja, mittlerweile wird es vermischt.
Retweeten ist für deine Follower.
Und für die Person, die es geschrieben hat.
Ja, eigentlich ist Tweeten und Retweeten,
liken und retweeten mittlerweile das gleiche.
Aber was du halt,
so habe ich mir das häufig verwendet, aber eigentlich,
wenn du dir mal was merken möchtest,
da hat jemand was Interessantes getweetet
oder einen Link gepostet oder auch sowas,
dann kannst du das halt liken.
Ich drücke dafür auf den Share-Button,
share und schickst mir selber per E-Mail.
Das hast du erzählt, genau.
Mittlerweile kannst du auf den Share-Button
und sagen, unter Bookmarks speichern.
Und dann hast du dir selber...
Da will ich niemals wieder reinschauen.
Wahrscheinlich steht da sogar schon Ding drin.
Kann man in meine Bookmarks reinschauen.
Ich versuche damit sparsam umzugehen.
Ja, aber ich schaue nicht rein.
Ich versuche zumindest.
Da gibt es zu viele Orte, wo man reinschauen muss.
Deswegen ist meine E-Mail-Inbox
das konsolidierteste Feed von Dingen,
die ich mir anschauen möchte.
Ich habe mich auch vor einigen Monaten mal hingesetzt
und mir Listen kuratiert in Twitter.
Um wirklich zu sagen,
ich habe eine Liste von Leuten,
die aus diesen Domänen kommen.
CPP, Dresden,
WebRTC. Aber die Leute schreiben ja nicht
nur über diese Themen, deswegen finde ich das auch ein bisschen
unslos. Ja, natürlich, das ist auch, aber
ich habe eine Liste, da ist
seit zehn Jahren habe ich die gefühlt,
da ist einfach niemand drin, die mache ich
manchmal einfach auf, dann ist die Liste schön leer.
Der Feed, finde ich toll.
Mal so ein leerer Feed kann auch
irgendwie befreiend wirken.
Nee, äh.
Es wäre cool, wenn bei Twitter nur das stehen
würde, was gerade jetzt passiert.
Und danach verschwindet es wie bei Snapchat.
Das ist ja auch geil.
Guckst du rein, was ist gerade los?
Manche Leute automatisieren das ja, indem sie ihre eigenen
Tweets nach ein paar Wochen automatisch löschen.
Dass alles, was
älter als Cut-Off ist, einfach
nicht mehr existiert.
Dann ist das wirklich so sehr ephemeral.
Ephemeral Tweets wäre cool.
Ich mache einen Tweet, der wieder weggeht.
Nee, ich habe noch zwei Pics.
Ja, bitte. Das erste heißt
AB Street. Was ist das?
Das ist ein Rust-Projekt.
Oh, das kenne ich noch nicht.
Das ist ein Spiel, das ist ein Traffic Simulation Game.
Das kenne ich.
Und es ist echt fancy.
Es ist nicht als Spiel gedacht, es ist aber auch ein Spielspiel.
Und es soll aber auch wirklich Simulationen erlauben für,
also du kannst ja glaube ich, soweit ich das verstanden habe,
direkt OSM-Daten importieren und quasi hier sagen,
ich möchte für diese Stadt hier, hier baue ich jetzt mal eine Straße,
oder hier ist eine Straße, hier füge ich mal eine Bike Lane mit ein.
Zum Beispiel.
Und so kannst du das halt da rangehen, so wie ich es verstanden habe.
Ich habe es bisher mal kurz gestartet,
bisschen mit rumgeklickt. Das läuft halt auch wunderbar.
Ist ja auch ein RAS-Projekt. Wird ja nur
von Leuten geschrieben, die Ahnung haben.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und es ist halt echt
ganz schick. Und ich mag solche Simulationen, wo du halt
du hast halt zum einen hier High-Level, so eine
ganze Stadt auf dem Bildschirm. Das ist ja auch im GIF
in der Readme für San Francisco. Und dann kannst du halt
reinzoomen, so weit, bis du halt wirklich
einzelne Fahrzeuge halt
an spezifischen Kreuzungen siehst.
Ja, das ist gut. Ich mag das, wenn
der komplette Stack da irgendwo
so eine große Simulation
finde ich schön. Diese GIFs sind schön,
das ist auf jeden Fall, das sieht aus,
da wuseln so kleine Punkte
auf Google Maps oder auf OpenStreetMaps hin und her.
Das ist nice.
Das erinnert mich an einen YouTube-Channel,
da gibt es einen,
der kriegt irgendwie die Welten,
es gibt dieses Spiel City Skylines
und da können sich Leute
ja auch Straßen bauen und
da fahren dann auch Autos drumherum
wie hier. Da kannst du auch eigentlich
ziemlich gut messen, wie ist
die Auslastung von dieser Straße, wo
sehst und du siehst es auch. Der YouTube-Channel
ist einfach bloß, der Typ kriegt irgendwie
die Cities von anderen Leuten geschickt,
die irgendwie gescheitert sind daran,
da irgendwie, die Cities
sind schön aus, aber es staut sich
irgendwie. Und dann macht er irgendwie ein 20-Minuten-Video
darüber, wie der die
Stadt optimiert. Ah ja, hier,
da hast du zwar fünf Spuren, aber das bringt überhaupt nichts.
Mach mal zwei wieder weg. Und dann, ah ja, hier,
guck mal, die biegen alle ab, aber die stauen sich
da alle. Machen wir mal hier noch eine...
Das sind relativ viele Videos.
Wir sind dann alle keine Städtepläne. Man kann halt
wirklich, da steckt halt erstaunlich viel auch
mit dahinter, um dass sowas halt im echten
Leben gut oder halt eben nicht gut funktioniert.
Aber, aber das ist ja was,
Biffa plays Indie Games, aber das ist genau das,
das ist, der kriegt ja
der kriegt hier
City Skylines Maps zugeschickt.
Pack mit den Show Notes.
Mach ich mal, das ist eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Ich geb mal hier eins von diesen Videos
einfach mal mit rein.
Wo hast du dein?
AppStreet, das da.
Cool, nice. Das letzte, was ich noch hab,
ist wieder ein Swift-Projekt.
hier mit meinem Lieblingsthema GraphQL
noch mit vereint und SwiftUI.
Genau, Graphallo oder
ähnlich ausgesprochen vermutlich.
Ist ein Projekt, das hat
der
Nerd Supremacist heißt er aufgetappt.
Ich habe gerade seinen echten Namen
vergessen oder seinen Real-Life-Name.
Genau, Matthias.
Die heißen meistens Matthias.
Ist ein super cooles Projekt, hat er vor kurzem
mal auf Twitter geteasert gehabt, fand ich da schon schick,
aber ich hatte es auch open-sourced.
ist ein bisschen Code, um dir, wenn du eine GraphQL-Schnittstelle hast,
um das mit SwiftUI direkt zu vereinen, dass du halt hier ein View hast
und sagst, dieser View, beziehungsweise dieser View hängt an diesem GraphQL-Typen
und sieht so aus.
Und dann wird das halt automatisch da reingebaut, die Daten werden populiert.
Du musst gar nichts mehr eigentlich machen.
Du musst bloß sagen, wo ist die Schnittstelle?
Und das ist der Typ, den ich hier an diesem View hänge.
Und dann läuft das.
Ich habe aber auch schon wieder so einige
Criticisms, die ich gerade nicht zusammenkriege,
zu GraphQL gehört. Meinst du, GraphQL wird
nächstes Jahr immer noch so ein geiles Thema sein?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, ob es ein geiles
Thema ist oder nicht, das entscheidet
irgendwie die Allgemeinheit.
Ich persönlich finde es immer noch sehr
schick und macht viele Dinge sehr angenehm.
Also spätestens als ich gesehen habe, dass es
in, wie heißt dieser Static Side Generator?
Welcher von
den zigtausend?
wo die Emma immer von Schwerer... Gatsby war vermutlich.
Gatsby, genau. Dass es in Gatsby
drin ist, um Static Sides zu generieren,
hab ich mir gedacht, naja, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen Overkill dafür.
Womöglich? Aber da
kannst du ja auch halbstatische Seiten
mitbauen. Oder wohl, da hab ich tatsächlich auch noch
einen anderen Pick, muss ich ganz sagen. Das ist der Static
Side Generator, der Swift, die Static Side Generator
von dem John Sandell,
der bekannt ist in der Swift-Welt.
Der hat nämlich sehr...
Also ich hab versucht, mit dem gerade eine Seite zu bauen.
Das wird eine Folge für zwei Folgen, weil wir einfach schon
so lange nichts mehr gemacht haben.
Ja, ich hol ein bisschen Sachen nach.
Ich habe letztens versucht, eine Seite damit zu bauen.
Der hat eine sehr interessante...
Wie heißt der jetzt überhaupt?
Das ist der Site Generator.
Heißt Publish.
Macht Sinn.
Stimmt, der hat ja gar nicht so einen spannenden Namen.
So heißen irgendwie alle Tools von dem.
Der hat eine Syntax-Highlighting-Engine, die heißt Plot.
Was hat das mit Syntax-Highlighting zu tun?
Der Name ist halt wie Dinge plotten.
Ah, okay.
Einfach schick hier.
Ein Wort.
Ein englisches, kurzes Wort.
Hier NPM Drinking Game und so weiter.
Hatten wir das hier schon gemacht?
Ja, ja, haben wir letzte Folge mit drin gehabt.
Das ist ja auch Kevin Herr.
Das wollte ich meinen Kollegen zeigen
und das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Der hat aber die
Idee verfolgt er damit, dass du
sehr wenig Dinge
außer dem eigentlichen Content
außerhalb deinem Code
deklarierst. Aber alles andere ist halt
in Code deklariert, wie auch
die Config für deine Seite,
wie das Theme ist halt in der HTML-DSL,
die er explizit dafür geschrieben hat,
die Typesafe-HTML macht,
was mega krass ist, aber machbar und schick.
Aber das liegt halt alles in Code.
Und wenn du halt hier nochmal ein Plugin schreibst,
was dir am Ende über alle Seiten drüber iteriert
und keine Ahnung, da ein Tag rewritet,
dann schreibst du das halt einfach als Funktion,
hängst das hier als Generation-Step mit rein
und das ist halt alles in Swift.
Und das fand ich echt schick und erstaunlich mächtig.
Swift Publish ist ungoogelbar.
einfach, du nimmst noch Draco.
Ich hab hier noch Static Side Generator
dazu geschrieben, dann ging's los.
Wenn du aus dem Zeichen Git Publish schreibst,
das ist der erste Hit. Ah ja, cool.
Genau.
Joa.
Nicht schlecht. Erwählen wir das nochmal mit,
weil ich's schick fand und gerade was damit gebaut hab.
Ja, Static Side Generators, da gibt's halt wirklich
unterschiedliche. Ich hab irgendwann
meine Seite jetzt zwischendurch
auf Solar umgestellt, weil ich
Gatsby, nee, weil ich
Jenkins
loswerden wollten. Nicht Jenkins.
Nicht Jenkins.
Jekyll. Jekyll war es, genau.
Jekyll und Hyde.
Aber irgendwie bringt jeder
seine, also das hat dann nochmal diese
Terra-Template-Engine, die ist aber
ganz okay, die wird zumindest auch von anderen RUST-Projekten
verwendet.
Aber
ich weiß nicht, ob ich einen Blog schreiben möchte,
wo jeder Blogpost
eine React-Komponente ist.
Okay.
Es geht. Also ich bin
noch nicht so richtig tief in
diese Static Side Generation Welt reingestiegen.
Was ich ganz cool finde, ist dieser
MD-Book-Trend,
dass jeder zu allem ein MD-Buch
schreibt. Wir werden jetzt
hoffentlich in der nächsten Zeit auch noch ein paar
neue Leute onboarden.
Da habe ich schon überlegt, ob ich über unser internes Projekt
einfach mal so ein MD-Buch schreibe, wo ich die
meisten Sachen zusammenfasse. Ist es tausendmal
besser, als das in irgendeiner Confluence-Seite
zu schreiben?
weil Confluence ist, wo Daten,
wo Informationen hingehen, um zu sterben.
Jo, ja.
Aber ja, schöne neue Welt.
Ich glaube, wir haben gerade einen Punkt erreicht.
Ich denke auch.
War eine gute Folge.
Ja, wir haben sehr viel nachgeholt
und sehr viel mal wieder über Programmiersprachen gewertet.
Finde ich sehr gut.
Also vielen lieben Dank,
dass ihr uns trotz der Audio Calamity
vom letzten Mal immer noch bis hierher angehört habt
Und als Wiedergutmachung bzw. als kleines Dankeschön dafür haben wir dieses Mal wieder einen kleinen Kulturbeitrag, den ich gerade ergoogle.
Google Kulturbeitrag.
Kulturbeitrag.
Nämlich, es gibt neue Musik von wunderschönen Dollar, STD-Out.
STD-Out, Stit-Out, Studio-Out.
Studio-Out.
Ich habe die SEDIO,
hatte ich mal Studio, Import Studio.
Ja, so klingt das auch.
So, damit geht das jetzt los.
Also, wir wünschen euch noch einen
erholsamen Tag.
Und
dieses Mal haben wir keinen Countdown, denn jetzt spielen wir einfach
Musik. Ja, der nächste Podcast
beginnt nach der Musik in 3, 2, 1.
Die Musik beginnt in 3,
2, 1.
If you had one interview with 28 steps, would you capture it or just let it slip?
His palms are sweaty, knees weak, arms are heavy.
There's typos in his code already, mind unsteady.
He's nervous, he was told his pairing session was friendly.
He prepped all week, now he's finding out he ain't ready.
Better think quick, he thought it would be about link lists.
Big twist, binary tree with the bid shift.
He sits with the fact that he probably won't finish it.
He's nitpicking lines while the clock just tick ticks.
Back to the rest of the day.
He's been here since eight.
Met so many faces.
Can't remember their names.
How many steps can an interview take?
They keep offering him coffee and bathroom breaks.
Long day with no rest.
Handshakes with cold sweat.
He hates these code tests.
Who knows who knows best?
Back to the keyboard again.
Time to do another algorithm that he never actually used.
You better lose yourself in the bullshit.
The process of longness.
You better never let it go.
You think it's all nonsense, do not let the company know
This opportunity's just another shitshow
You better lose yourself in the bullshit, the process, the longness
You better never let it go
You think it's all nonsense, do not let the company know
This opportunity's just another shitshow
Caffeine depleting, dry lips started bleeding
From fake smiles every meeting
Just who left as he moved towards a few more of moral hypocrites
Checking culture fit
Like what's your biggest weakness? Don't be too honest.
And what's your biggest strength? Remember to be modest.
Seem eager to learn. Don't act like you lack knowledge.
Try to be casual. Don't be unpolished.
Have strong opinions and remain open.
Show you just go with the flow, but stay focused.
Then the tables turn. They ask him to ask them.
But their answers are all fluff and hot trends.
He notices all these folks just keep quoting the CEO.
Like is this a job or a cult?
He knows he needs dough, so he goes along
Then he realizes in his challenge that a pointer was null
You better lose yourself in the bullshit, the process of longness
You better never let it go
You think it's all nonsense, do not let the company know
This opportunity's just another shit show
You better lose yourself in that bullshit, the process of longness
You better never let it go
You think it' all nonsense, do not let the company know
This opportunity's just another shit show
Outro Music